Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim
Prittlaff und das hier ist Ausgabe 144 von UKW.
Und ja, heute, ich habe ja immer so einen Themennamen am Anfang des Titels,
wo ich sage, heute geht es um das.
Und da weiß ich gar nicht, was ich da reinschreiben soll, weil heute geht es irgendwie um alles.
Heute geht es ein bisschen um Ukraine, es geht auch ein bisschen um Kurdistan,
es geht auch um den Iran-Krieg und wahrscheinlich auch noch um den Rest der Welt.
Und ja, Ant ist wahrscheinlich schon, das heißt, Enno ist da.
Hallo, vielleicht ist es sowas wie Dinge, wo die Amis rumrühren oder so als,
nicht alle, aber so ein paar.
Die rühren ja überall rum, von daher.
Alles nicht ganz falsch.
Ja, es wird viel rumgerührt. Kurz, wir wollen so ein bisschen mal wieder eine
subjektivere Perspektive vielleicht auch noch mit einbringen,
weil du warst wieder viel unterwegs und darüber wollen wir sprechen,
aber wir wollen natürlich auch ein bisschen darüber reflektieren,
wie der Iran-Krieg konkret jetzt auch das Geschehen in der Ukraine beeinflusst,
denn das tut er auf vielerlei Arten und Weisen, in a good way und auch in a bad way.
Genau und darum soll es heute gehen bei UKW.
Wir haben jetzt leider schon seit längerem, wieder seit drei,
vier Wochen keine wirkliche Zusammenfassung des bisherigen Geschehens im Krieg gemacht.
Da ist auf der einen Seite eine ganze Menge passiert im Detail und das werden
wir sicherlich auch nebenbei noch so ein bisschen ansprechen.
Im Großen und Ganzen kann man aber sagen, was jetzt das eigentliche Kriegsgeschehen
betrifft, ist es eine Fortführung dessen, was wir hier auch in der letzten Sendung schon gesagt haben.
Das heißt, auf der einen Seite, die Russen kommen derzeit nicht so richtig voran.
Und es macht auch derzeit so den Eindruck, dass sie in zunehmendem Maße immer
weniger nicht vorankommen.
Also da bricht einiges auseinander. Alle haben ja mit einer großen Spring Offensive gerechnet.
Also wenn halt das Eis weg ist und dann auch der Schlamm erstmal weg ist,
dann gibt es ja wieder die Möglichkeit, mit größerem Gerät vorzustoßen oder
auf breiter Front in irgendeiner Form was zu machen.
Aber das scheint jetzt weitgehend ausgehebelt worden zu sein.
Einerseits Materialmangel, andererseits vielleicht auch ein Personalmangel.
Da, wo sie Zahlen haben, haben sie zumindest...
Keine wirklich gut ausgebildeten Soldaten mehr, weil einfach ihr Churn so dermaßen
hoch ist, dass die Leute da, wenn sie quasi im Kriegsgebiet ankommen,
naja, dann leben die halt auch nicht lange, wenn die da an die Front geschickt werden.
Mit anderen Worten, ohne viel Erfahrung. Und was sich halt auch nach wie vor
auswirkt, ist dieses Abschalten von Starlink,
das hat den Russen wirklich so richtig die Beine weggezogen und auf der anderen Seite eine Ukraine,
die glaube ich jetzt mit neuen Produktionsmöglichkeiten im Drohnenkrieg, mit neuen Strategien,
auch in der Art und Weise, wie sie den Russen begegnen und dem Ausdehnen dieser
Greyzone auf teilweise vielleicht sogar bis zu 30, 40.
Vielleicht sogar 50 Kilometer, je nachdem, es einfach den Russen sehr,
sehr, sehr schwer macht, in irgendeiner Form noch mit ihrer Logistik hinterher zu kommen.
Das ist das eine. Auf der anderen Seite sind es natürlich auch die immer weiter
ins Land gehenden Schläge auf ihre Infrastruktur.
Ich habe auch so den Eindruck, dass speziell diese Firma Firepoint hier eine
besondere Rolle spielt.
Vor allem diese Firepoint 1 und Firepoint 2-Drohnen, die so in letzter Zeit
den Eindruck erwecken, dass das so das schärfste Schwert zu sein scheint.
Also mehr noch als diese, die machen ja auch diese Flamingo,
über die viel geredet wurde.
Die kommt auch teilweise zum Einsatz, aber die ist einfach noch zu groß,
zu langsam, noch zu leicht abzuschießen.
Aber mit diesen Firepoint 2 Drohnen, das sind halt Drohnen, die relativ tief
ins Land fliegen können und in zunehmendem Maße auch immer eine größere Sprengkraft haben.
Die bauen auch gerade irgendwie um und jetzt kommt so ein Redesign mit rein,
dass sie also noch mehr Zerstörungskraft entwickeln.
Und da gelingt es einfach der Ukraine in zunehmendem Maße durchzudringen auf
große Distanzen und richtig dem Ganzen gar auszumachen.
Die absolute Krönung dessen in den letzten Wochen war der Angriff auf gleich
zwei Terminals in der Ostsee.
Die wichtigsten Öl-Terminals neben dem schon weitgehend ausgeschalteten Terminal in Novorossisk,
also im Schwarzen Meer und dann gibt es auch noch dieses Gas-Terminal in dem
Ort, den ich jetzt gerade vergessen habe.
Aber Ust Luga und Primors, das sind so die beiden Orte.
Und auf der südlichen und auf der nördlichen Seite dieses Arms der Ostsee, der dann bis St.
Petersburg sich erstreckt, an diesen beiden Stellen, da wird eigentlich im Wesentlichen
das meiste Öl verklappt.
Ja, und abgesehen davon, dass Schweden und UK zunehmendem Maße auch sich so
da die Tanker schnappen, die nicht so versichert sind, wie das so sein soll
und die eben sanktioniert sind,
haben die Russen jetzt einfach das Problem, dass da gerade alles brennt.
Weil sie einfach mit diesen Drohnen dort reingegangen sind, mehrere Schläge
im Abstand von zwei, drei Tagen gemacht haben.
Also sie haben immer feste Drohf und dann geguckt, bis der Rauch weg ist und
dann nochmal die Satellitenbilder anschauen und dann nochmal feste drauf und
nochmal feste drauf. Und das geht jetzt hier irgendwie schon seit Wochen so.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt gibt es, also zum Zeitpunkt dieser Aufnahme,
den Zeitpunkt könnte ich mal nennen. Was haben wir denn heute?
Ostermontag ist der 6. April 26. Zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist seit zwei Wochen kein
einziger Öltanker mehr in der Ostsee beladen worden von den Russen.
Also gerade jetzt, wo der Irankrieg die Preise ins Unermessliche steigen lässt,
kann Russland nicht wirklich davon profitieren.
Es wird zwar jetzt mehr Geld für Öl bezahlt, aber die Ukraine verhindert gerade,
dass Russland sein Öl überhaupt exportiert bekommt.
Die Vogelperspektive des Geschehens derzeit, fällt dir da noch was zu ein?
Ja, was mir immer wieder auffällt ist, wir haben uns nur so total daran gewöhnt,
die Drohnen, die die einsetzen, um sowas anzugreifen, sind zwar,
sagen wir, die aktuellen modernen Drohnen.
Das sind jetzt keine Wundermittel mit irgendwie Stealth und Hyperspeed oder
irgendwas, sondern die tuckern relativ konventionell dahin.
Und das zeigt ja, dass die für 1000 Kilometer oder so Strecke in Russland keine
richtige Flugabwehr mehr haben.
Keine Erkennung auch nur davon. Niemand, der es runter... Also entweder erkennen sie es nicht.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, weil so geheim sind die Dinger nicht.
Sondern sie haben nichts mehr stehen, was es erkennen könnte.
Und das ist inzwischen normal nach vier Jahren Krieg, dass das so schlecht ist,
aber hätte man vor fünf Jahren einem gesagt, lass uns mal so eine drei Meter
Sperrholzdrohne mit einem Verbrennermotor über Russland tuckern lassen,
da hätte man doch gesagt, ey du, das wird nichts.
Also das wäre ja wie mit einer Cessna auf den roten Platz fliegen oder so,
das wird nie im Leben funktionieren.
Aber so die Älteren unter uns erinnern sich als Herr Rust der Flugschüler das mal.
Gemacht hat zum.
Glück Ende der 80er wo das so nicht so schlimm genommen wurde der ist ja sogar
ein paar mal aufgeschnappt worden von irgendwelchen Radaren aber die haben das
nicht ernst genommen 28.
Mai 87 der hatte auch echt Glück dass es so spät war, wo das so,
also fünf Jahre vorher wäre die Nummer wahrscheinlich noch anders ausgegangen.
Ja, aber trotzdem, das ist so, das ist so bizarr, mit was für verhältnismäßig
schlechten Dingen das geht.
Und ich erinnere mich halt so vor fünf bis zehn Jahren auf den Rüstungsmessen,
wenn die Experten da erzählt haben, die haben gesagt, also nie wieder siehst
du Panzer gegen Panzer oder sowas.
Das wird jetzt mit so kleinen spezialisierten Sabotage-Trupps gemacht und Weltraum
und Cyber und fast alles, was wir da sehen, also sei es jetzt im Iran oder auch in der Ukraine.
Also ich meine, die Drohnen werden immer weiterentwickelt, klar,
aber das ist jetzt mal salopp gesagt Kram von AliExpress und von Amazon und
es sind weiterhin im Kern Sachen, die 10, 20 Jahre alte Technik sind,
also das Große und Ganze.
Also ich meine, wenn man jetzt in die Details geht, klar, so eine FPV-Drohne
hat sich weiterentwickelt, aber jetzt sagen wir mal irgendwie eine Drohne mit
einer Bombe drunter, die haben ja das Rad nicht neu erfunden.
Oder auch diese Flamingo FP7, am Ende ist es halt eine Cruise Missile,
also da gibt es so verschiedene Sachen da, die nutzen Cruise Missiles,
die nutzen ballistische Raketen.
Flamingo ist glaube ich FP5, FP7 ist die neue ballistische.
Die jetzt noch kommt. Diese S-300-Klon, ja. Ja, genau, aber ich meine,
das ist, also, das sind halt nicht die Waffen, die wir bei Star Trek gesehen haben.
Oder nicht der geheime Scheiß aus dem Labor, sondern es ist relativ konventionell
alles irgendwie noch. Und das finde ich so interessant.
Also jetzt Drohnen schwärmen und so, klar, da wird es ein bisschen spannender.
Aber selbst richtig KI sehen wir kaum. Es gibt so ein bisschen Pixelzählen in
Drohnen oder so. Aber so die bahnbrechenden Neuerungen, also die Dinge,
wo du sagst, boah, wie kann diese Technologie heute existieren?
Das fehlt mir irgendwie. Und das wäre ja so meine Erwartung gewesen,
dass man das im Krieg jetzt entscheidet mit den bizarrsten Hightech-Waffen aus
dem James-Bond-Film und eben
nicht mit Sachen wie einer Scharhead oder so einem Scheiß, der einfach...
Modern ist von der Idee her. Und klar, die haben jetzt neuere Mesh-Modems drin
und hin und her, aber im Kern halt eine Bombe, Flügel, Motor,
das ist alles nicht so beeindruckend.
Ja gut, ich meine, im Krieg geht es natürlich auch um die Ausnutzung der Schwächen.
Und eine Technologie ist immer nur so gut, wie sie verhindert werden kann.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht haben halt so diese Schahets einfach eine Lücke ausgenutzt,
weil man einfach dafür nicht geplant hat, wie die fliegt niedrig und langsam.
Und darauf waren dann einfach die ganzen Radarsysteme, Meldeketten und eben
auch die Abwehrsysteme nicht vorbereitet.
Und auch die Ukraine muss sich ja da erstmal was einfallen lassen.
Und insofern, ich meine, wenn du jetzt sagst AliExpress, das nehme ich jetzt
mal als Vergleich, weil mittlerweile ist es ja so, dass die Ukraine,
so wie ich das sehe, den Großteil der Technologie auch im Land entwickelt.
Einerseits, weil das natürlich dann schneller geht, weil es dann mehr auf ihre
Bedürfnisse zugeschnitten ist und vor allem, weil sie natürlich auch nicht jetzt
von China abhängen wollen, wie sehr sie an diesem Krieg teilnehmen können.
Aber da ist natürlich schon eine ganze Menge Innovation jetzt auch passiert,
speziell was diese Interceptor-Drohnen angeht, also wiederum sozusagen die Denial-of-Service
für diese Schahed-Drohnen, ja,
die ihrerseits auch wieder natürlich aufrüsten durch.
Verbesserte Technologie oder auch die Kombination dass da jetzt auch Kameras
drauf sind, dass sie also auch zum Ausspionieren genutzt werden etc.
Also es ist ein permanentes Wettrüsten und dieses Wettrüsten findet einfach
im totalen Zeitraffer statt also das hat man ja auch gesehen dass alle anderen,
die jetzt an diesem Krieg nicht aktiv teilnehmen, das sind ja leider sehr viele,
die das nicht tun ähm,
dass die irgendwo jetzt auch abgehängt werden. Und das sehen wir im Iran-Krieg,
so wie die Amerikaner jetzt einfach gerade mal da mit runtergelassenen Hosen
versuchen, da einen Krieg mit ihrer konventionellen Technologie durchzuführen.
Aber alle ihre US-Basen hat räumen müssen im Golfbereich, weil sie einfach gegen
diesen Drohnenkrieg keine Antwort haben.
Es war auch, wann war denn das? vor ein, zwei Monaten, als die paar russischen
Gerbera-Drohnen über Polen geflogen sind.
Und dann hieß ja, aber wir haben eine F-35 aus den Niederlanden geholt und die
hat dann so eine Gerbera abgeschossen.
Ich finde, geil, ihr habt 1000 Kilometer Anflug mit einem der teuersten Flugzeuge
der Welt und eine Million Rakete gebraucht, um eine 20.000 Euro Pappdrohne abzuschießen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das skaliert.
Wir wissen, ob das skaliert.
Das kann ich nicht.
Ja, nur so, also irgendwie mit diesem Hightech, also ich meine, klar,
man muss viel abdecken, aber irgendwie da sieht man doch, hey,
wir sind jetzt im vierten Jahr von dieser Art von Krieg schon,
da kommen wir zu uns fünfte und ihr meint immer noch, das ist die Lösung.
Also irgendwie, ja, ich weiß nicht.
Also es ist halt so ein bisschen, erinnert es mich an Steampunk oder halt,
wie sie es ja immer nennen, so Erster Weltkrieg, aber mit Drohnen,
also so eine Mischung aus beidem.
Aber ja, viele, also gerade die EU-Länder hat man halt das Gefühl,
ich weiß nicht, ob die keinen Fernseher haben oder warum die da nicht hinterherkommen.
Ja, hat einfach noch keiner Bescheid gesagt.
Ja, und auch ich war nur einen Punkt noch vor einer Weile bei der Bundeswehr
und durfte mir da Drohnen angucken.
Und die hatten so ein Ding, das sah aus wie so diese allererste DJI-Drohne,
diese große, klobige Phantom oder irgendwas, oder was weiß ich, was damals war.
Also die erste, die es so unter dem Weihnachtsbaum gab und hatte so ungefähr
die Auflösung vom VHS-Kammcorder und war echt laut wie ein Trecker.
Und ich weiß nicht, ich hab's dann gegoogelt, das Ding ist so zehn Jahre alt
und die sagten, naja, der Beschaffungsprozess ist halt so lang, deswegen.
Und ich dachte, okay, ja, viel Erfolg mit der Mühle, die könnte einen Katapult
spannen und rüberschießen oder so. Ich weiß nicht, ob die viel mehr macht im Krieg.
Okay, also um mal diesen Block erstmal abzuschließen, nach wie vor ist die Ukraine
unter Beschuss, nach wie vor gibt es.
Zu wenig Gegenwehr gegen ballistische Raketen der Russen und andere Missiles,
das ist ein Versorgungsproblem,
weil Patriot-Systeme gibt es eigentlich genug, nur die Raketen werden halt derzeit
auf billige Schahed-Drohnen im Golf geschossen, anstatt in der Ukraine richtig
zum Einsatz gebracht zu werden.
Das ist halt alles sehr dramatisch. Aber insgesamt, die Ukraine hat es geschafft,
die Russen zu stoppen. So würde ich das jetzt mal halten.
Und nicht nur wie bisher im Schwarzen Meer, sondern eben mehr oder weniger auf
der vollständigen Front.
Die Russen machen derzeit keine Fortschritte. Fortschritte machen die Ukrainer.
Diese Fortschritte befinden sich im hunderte von Quadratkilometern Bereich,
was im Verhältnis zu der Gesamtkriegszone jetzt auch nicht mega viel ist,
aber zumindest ist das Vorzeichen umgedreht worden.
Und es sieht derzeit nicht unbedingt so aus, dass die Russen hier in irgendeiner
Form in der Lage sind, in absehbarer Zeit das Rad da zu drehen.
Dazu kommt, dass sich mittlerweile eine extreme Unruhe, so auch im Netz den
kriegbegleitenden Gruppierungen,
also diese ganzen Warbloggern und andere Leute, also man hört immer mehr Skepsis,
man hört immer mehr Alarmismus, man hört auch Kritik.
Ja klar, die Leute kritisieren dann Putin, dann sind sie zwei Wochen später
in irgendeinem Krankenhaus und werden mal psychologisch betreut.
Aber insgesamt ist einfach die Situation nicht gut und durch diese Angriffe
auf Ustluga und auf Primorsk wird das jetzt auch nicht besser werden,
weil jetzt können die Russen noch nicht mal mehr ihr Öl verkaufen und da das
nun mal die Hauptquelle zur Finanzierung dieses Krieges ist, wird es schwierig.
Jetzt musste Putin halt die Umsatzsteuer erhöhen, das war jetzt auch nicht besonders populär,
alle Gemeinden sind pleite, also es gibt derzeit einfach relativ wenig Möglichkeiten
hier in irgendeiner Form finanziell sich noch zu verbessern und das wird mittelfristig
irgendwann dann auch mal eine Auswirkung haben, zwangsläufig.
Ja und die Russen hatten ja auch mal grob gesagt ihr ganzes Tafelsilber jetzt auch verkauft.
Also so Sachen, mit denen man sich eine Weile über Bord halten kann.
Irgendwelche Anleihen, irgendwelche anderen Sachen.
Gold.
Genau Gold. Also all diese Dinge. Man sagt, ja, das geht schon eine Weile.
Aber wenn alle, dann alle.
Und ich meine, die Prognosen finde ich immer so ein bisschen schwierig,
weil es immer heißt, nächsten Monat sind die pleite. Aber ich meine, es wird nicht mehr.
Also an allen Ecken und Enden wird es weniger. Und wenn sich das dann irgendwann
mal trifft, also der Ölexport und das Gold und die Sachen.
Geht es halt ganz steil runter.
Genau. Okay, also das vielleicht mal so zur Gesamtsituation Ukraine,
um das schon mal erwähnt zu haben.
Wir werden auf ein paar Aspekte davon nochmal eingehen.
Ich möchte jetzt aber noch ein bisschen zurückspulen und zurückgehen in den
Januar, weil im Januar hast du das letzte Mal die Ukraine wieder konkret bereist.
Vielleicht erinnerst du dich sogar in etwa wann?
Ja, erste Januarwoche, weil das war ukrainisches Weihnachten,
das heißt nicht ukrainisches Weihnachten, aber die feiern ja,
da gibt es dann aber noch Nuancen irgendwie,
aber grob als hier Nikolaus war, war da Weihnachten,
da waren wir in Kherson und haben Weihnachtsgeschenke geliefert.
Also Kherson ist ja Frontstadt, kann man sagen.
Wir hatten auch schon mal drüber berichtet. Da ist nicht schön.
Nach wie vor sehr viele Drohnenangriffe durch die Russen vom anderen Seite des Dnipro-Ufers.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob sich an der Situation selbst groß was geändert hat.
Es ist ja nach wie vor Sperrbereich.
Da darfst du jetzt nur hin, weil du Journalistenstatus hast.
Ja, es ist sogar ein Pressesperrgebiet. Also es ist Red Zone,
aber wir nennen es immer den NO-Ausweis.
Also es gibt immer noch einen, mit dem man durchkommt.
Und wenn man mit zweieinhalbtausend Weihnachtsgeschenken kommt,
dann kommt man überall durch.
Aber ja, es gibt eingeschränkten Zugang für Journalisten, aber auch es ist in
dem Fall nachvollziehbar, weil es ist unglaublich gefährlich,
vor allem jetzt, wo es wärmer wird, wo die Drohnenakkus wieder halten.
Ich glaube, gestern sind 10 oder 15 Fahrzeuge in der Stadt bombardiert worden,
also einfach so halbwegs wahllos Fahrzeuge mit Drohnen angegriffen.
Ja genau und da wohnen vielleicht 20.000, 30.000 Leute noch.
Also es ist ein bisschen schwierig, weil es keiner richtig zählt.
Aber da sind auch 15 Fahrzeuge schon eine Menge. Also das ist wirklich signifikant.
Heute waren Angriffe auf den Ort, wo wir die Weihnachtsgeschenke verteilt haben.
Da kam vorhin auch die Nachricht, eine unserer Partnerorganisationsdamen vor
Ort, mit der wir die Weihnachtsgeschenke verteilt haben, ist beim Angriff heute
Morgen auch getötet worden in der Einrichtung.
Also da merkt man halt, es wird intensiver wieder, wenn es wärmer wird und es
kommt auch so persönlich näher.
Und im Januar war es zum Glück so kalt, dass sich das vor allem auf die Drohnen-Akkus
auswirkt, also auf die FPV-Drohnen-Akkus.
Und ganz grob ist es im Winter so, dass sie so gerade eben über den Fluss kommen
und wenn sie genau wissen, wo sie hinwollen, ein Ziel genauer anfliegen können,
wenn es sich nicht bewegt.
Und jetzt, wo es wärmer wird, haben die aber wieder so fünf Minuten,
zehn Minuten, um ein Ziel zu suchen.
Also das ist so der relevante Unterschied.
Und deswegen geht es jetzt langsam wieder los, weil die jetzt halt in die Stadt
reinfliegen können und dann gucken, nehme ich Auto eins, zwei oder drei.
Ja, und die Lage aber da ist, also es ist so die wildeste Stadt,
die ich überhaupt noch besuche und auch inzwischen nur noch,
also früher sind wir hingefahren und ein, zwei Tage geblieben und inzwischen
fahren wir im Prinzip rein, machen das Nötigste, das Gespräch,
was wir brauchen, die Geschenk abliefern oder wie auch immer,
dann ins Auto und sofort wieder raus.
Weil es einfach immens gefährlich geworden ist.
Wie lange warst du dann da?
Ein paar Stunden. Also wir sind abends nach Odessa gefahren,
also quasi nebenan, um da zu schlafen. Das ist so eine Stunde oder anderthalb mit dem Auto weiter.
Im Hotel Bristol, was nachdem ich vor einer Weile da war, eine Woche später
bombardiert worden ist und inzwischen aber wieder auf hat.
Nur die oberste Etage nicht, weil da noch nicht wieder aufgeräumt ist.
Das ist so das Journalistenhotel.
Und da gibt es immer noch eine Kinderbibliothek, die da geöffnet hat,
weil da auch immer noch Kinder sind.
Den hatten wir so Powerstations und Infrarotheizung und sowas gespendet und
die wollten uns halt zeigen, dass die noch da sind, dass das alles in Benutzung
ist und dann so nach drei, vier Stunden oder sowas rausgefahren.
Also man fährt zu Odessa, Mikolaiv und dann runter nach Kherson.
Ist auch ein Problem, wenn man sich das auf der Karte anguckt.
Es gibt eine Straße im Prinzip von Mikolaiv nach Kherson.
Das ist die einzige, die man benutzen kann. Das ist auch kein Geheimnis,
das weiß jeder, das wissen die Russen auch.
Da ist der längste Netztunnel der Ukraine, also so Netze, Antidrohennetze,
die komplett über die Straße gespannt sind. Da sieht es aus wie so eine Autobahn.
Das letzte Mal war der ungefähr zwölf Kilometer lang.
Und in Rerson sind auch viele Straßen überspannt und sogar der Kreisverkehr.
Und dann, das sieht aus wie so ein Spielzeug für Katzen oder so,
wo sich mehrere Tunnel treffen im Kreisverkehr, nur eben in groß.
Und am Ende von den Tunneln oder da, wo die Netze aufhören, da lauern aber oft die Drohnen.
Also die landen und warten, bis ein Fahrzeug kommt und fliegen einem dann in die Seite.
Und das ist so bizarr. Also man kommt an und vor dem Tunnel ist eine Ampel,
die die Armee schaltet und grün heißt Himmel sieht frei aus und rot heißt nicht frei.
Aber grün heißt nicht, du bist garantiert sicher, sondern nur wir sehen nichts.
Genau und dann sagen die halt fahr Vollgas durch den Tunnel,
also so sechs, sieben Minuten Vollgas und dann fahr genau dahin, wo du hin musst.
Weil also nicht draußen rumlaufen, nicht lang parken, also im Prinzip bremsen
raus und in den Keller geht's.
Und auch die Anweisungen sind schon bizarr.
Sie sagen, wenn der Wagenvorder hinter dir abgeschossen wird,
nicht stehen bleiben, weil dann schießen die dich ab, sondern direkt weiterfahren.
Und genau am Tunnelende kann es sein, dass jemand anfängt zu schießen,
wenn er eine Drohne sieht, die da parkt.
Also nicht wundern, wenn du aufs Tunnelende zufährst und jemand über dein Auto hinweg schießt.
Wenn man das vorher weiß, dann ist es okay.
Und weil wir da halt auch nur mit gepanzerten Autos hinfahren,
dann hieß es dann immer, ihr dürft gerne als Erster fahren, weil wenn da eine
Drohne ist, habt ihr die beste Chance.
Also viel Glück, wir drücken euch
die Daumen und wir sehen euch in sieben Minuten auf der anderen Seite.
Aber das ist schon, also es ist wirklich eine ganz andere Welt,
wenn man da durch diesen Tunnel hinfährt.
Sonst kannte ich so Tunnel, da ist man so ein paar Sekunden durchgefahren, so 20, 30 Sekunden.
Aber da ist es halt wirklich, je nachdem, wie schnell man fährt,
so fünf bis zehn Minuten, also die Größenordnung.
Und am Ende ist dann entweder Rehason oder auf der anderen Seite eine Tankstelle,
wo es diese Hotdogs gibt.
Und so das, womit die Leute sich da immer beruhigen, ist, wenn du es geschafft
hast, gibt es einen Hotdog. Also deswegen alles gut.
Am Ende gibt es einen Hotdog.
Immerhin.
Wie es, also ich meine, du hast gesagt, ungefähr noch 30.000 Leute.
Ja.
Das waren mal 300.000 in dieser Stadt, also das ist also schon ziemlich entvölkert
und ich nehme mal an, von diesen 30.000 sind eine ganze Menge auch Soldaten letzten Endes.
Also im Prinzip Soldaten und dann halt so Rettungsdienst,
Stadtreinigung, also ist auch so komisch, der, selbst das,
Grünflächenamt ist da noch und mehr Rasen, also das ist so, das ist so eine
bizarre Mischung, also du hast halt irgendwie im Sommer dutzende bis hunderte
Drohnen am Tag, aber die Pflanzen werden noch geschnitten, die auf der Straße stehen.
Und so Sachen, die Stadtreinigung fegt die Straßen noch, sagen,
das ist aber tatsächlich wichtig, damit man sieht, wo Sprengkörper runtergekommen sind.
Also auch so Verbindungen, die man gar nicht so auf dem Schirm hat,
dass so eine Arbeit so relevant sein kann.
Dann gibt es halt viel alte Leute, die einfach nicht wegziehen wollen, die einfach da bleiben.
Und dann gibt es ein paar, es gibt noch eine Pizzeria, es gibt noch einen Supermarkt,
es gibt noch so ein paar Sachen, die laufen und die laufen auch ganz normal.
Also der Supermarkt hat weiterhin irgendwie Milka-Schokolade und sowas.
Also die haben auch keinen Engpass an irgendwas.
Also das ist halt so strange, weil es halt wirklich richtig entvölkert ist.
Und wenn man Auto fährt, fährt man im Prinzip Vollgas da, wo man hin muss und bleibt dann stehen.
Das heißt aber, die anderen fahren auch so. Das heißt, es ist ein bisschen wie so ein Videospiel.
Alle fahren Vollgas und alle gucken in alle Richtungen, dass sie sich nicht
rammen. Und dann bremst einer, springt raus und holt sich eine Pizza.
Und es ist halt, also es ist so eine wirklich eigene Welt.
Und die Kinder sind zum Teil noch da, weil es dann oft die Kinder sind von jemandem
in der Verwaltung, in der Stadtreinigung, im Rettungsdienst,
also von den Soldaten meist nicht, weil die nicht von da kommen,
die sind fast immer von woanders.
Na, dadurch ist es so eine ganz merkwürdige Mischung und die Leute gewöhnen sich ja dran.
Das heißt, wie gesagt, es gibt noch die Bücherei, wo die Kinder ihre Bücher
ausleihen und es gibt halt den Supermarkt, wo der Supermarkt normal auf hat,
Und währenddessen knallt es dauernd in der Stadt.
Also wirklich dauernd, den ganzen Tag, von morgens bis abends,
hört man irgendwo Einschläge.
Und deswegen bringt auch die Luftalarm-App oder so nichts, weil im Prinzip haben
die seit vier Jahren Alarm.
Also da braucht man jetzt nicht darauf achten, ist es jetzt gerade akut oder nicht.
Manchmal kommen Gleitbomben rein, manchmal Scharhets, meistens FPV drohen.
Und halt je dichter man zum Fluss kommt, desto gefährlicher.
Auch so ein Punkt ist, es gibt ja Straßen, wenn man über einen Fluss guckt,
in die man gerade reingucken kann vom anderen Flussufer aus.
Das sind die, die man meiden muss, weil da auch manchmal russische Scharfschützen reinschießen.
Das heißt, man hat eigentlich immer Google Maps auf, wenn man sich nicht auskennt.
Und wenn man sich auskennt, weiß man, welche Straßen das sind.
Dass man immer nur quasi parallel zum Fluss fährt, aber nicht auf den Fluss
zu oder davon weg, wenn es irgendwie sich einrichten lässt.
Es sind halt so eigene Regeln, eigene Welt.
Und die Leute vor Ort, die sind aber im Großen und Ganzen ganz normal.
Also die wohnen da halt zum Teil den ganzen Krieg jetzt durch und die haben
sich einfach dran gewöhnt, dass das so ist und dass es halt ein paar sehr merkwürdige
Regeln gibt, nachdem man da sich bewegt.
Unglaublich. Also es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass jetzt bestimmte Teile der
Stadt irgendwie komplett geräumt werden an Flussnähe oder so.
Die Leute sind einfach, wo sie sind.
Ja und sagen wir direkt am Fluss ist eigentlich fast alles leer und es gibt
den Bereich, das nennen die die Insel, das ist so,
also es ist auch wirklich wie eine große Insel, aber es ist so ein ganzer Stadtteil,
der mit im Kern mit einer Brücke oder vielleicht waren es mal zwei,
aber einer großen Brücke verbunden ist.
Und die große Brücke ist jetzt vor ein paar Monaten bombardiert worden.
Also die steht noch und wer mutig ist, kann rüberfahren, aber die hat ein paar Löcher.
Also die ist nicht eingestürzt, aber die ist auch nicht mehr vertrauenserweckend.
Aber diese Insel, wie sie es nennen, also so ein Stadtviertelgroßes Ding,
ist auch nicht zwingend geräumt, sondern da sind immer noch Leute, die da leben.
Und ich glaube, die haben es aufgegeben mit sowas wie Zwangsevakuierung,
sondern die sagen, hey, du weißt ja, wie die Lage ist, aber sollen wir jetzt
jeden Einzelnen aus der Wohnung ziehen?
Taugt auch nicht. Und es gibt halt so Gegenden, ganz grob gesagt,
ist es im Osten gefährlicher als im Westen der Stadt, aber halt auch,
das sind eher so Nuancen.
Also das ist so, die Deutschen meinen, Ukraine ist gefährlich und die Ukrainer
sagen, im Osten ist gefährlich und die im Osten sagen, in Kherson ist gefährlich
und die sagen wieder, in dem Stadtteil ist gefährlich. Also es kommt halt immer
so auf die Perspektive an.
Und Antonivka, was halt im Osten, also quasi direkt angrenzt an Reasson,
wie so ein Vorort oder so, aber fährt man durch, als sei es eine Stadt, das ist fast leer.
Und da war die große, wie so die Autobahnbrücke auf die südliche Seite vom Dinepro
Richtung Krim letzten Endes. Also noch ein ganzes Stück bis zum Krim.
Also die Atomovsky-Brücke, die ja dann durch das gezielte Bombardement der Ukrainer
dann zerstört wurde, nachdem die Russen abgezogen sind aus diesem Gebiet.
Und deswegen halt, da ist es sehr gefährlich und je weiter nach West man so
in Raison kommt, desto verhältnismäßig ungefährlicher wird es,
aber das ist alles wirklich so Kleinkram an Unterschieden.
Und man muss schon so 50 bis 100 Kilometer weg, damit es, sagen wir mal,
akzeptabel sicher ist für halbwegs normale Menschen.
Auch Odessa ist halt auch nicht sicher.
Jeden Tag gibt es da jetzt wieder schlimme Angriffe drauf.
Also alles den Fluss lang, alles im Süden lang.
Also das ist halt so, wie man sich Front im Prinzip vorstellt,
also wo es dauert, knallt.
Ja, es gab ja, das ist jetzt auch schon wieder Jahre her,
ich weiß jetzt gar nicht ganz genau, aber der Novakowka-Damm, also der große Damm,
der den Dnipro aufgestaut hat und der ja eigentlich zu diesem großen Dnipro-Becken geführt hat.
Wie der Bodensee, fast so groß, also ein Riesending.
Ein Riesensee, der ist halt gesprengt worden von den Russen.
Warum auch immer, also ich weiß nicht, so einen richtigen strategischen Vorteil
haben sie davon jetzt irgendwie auch nicht gehabt, außer dass sie damit die
Wasserversorgung für die Krim gekappt haben.
Also von daher war das irgendwie auch eine ziemlich idiotische Geschichte,
aber ich habe so den Eindruck, damit wollten sie dann irgendwie,
naja, irgendwann ist das dann ausgetrocknet und dann haben wir da quasi auf
breiter Front auch wieder Zugang zu diesem Gebiet.
Das war vielleicht so ein bisschen der Vater des Gedankens, aber keine Ahnung,
ob das jemals rauskommen wird.
Trotz alledem, worauf ich hinaus wollte, ist, auf der einen Seite hat natürlich
die Sprengung des Dams in diesem Becken und damit ja auch vor der Stadt Reasson
eine ziemliche Überflutung ausgelöst.
Die hat sich zwar im Wesentlichen auf den südlichen Teil, also den nicht von
Reasson abgedeckten Teil bezogen, aber ich glaube, Teile sind auch davon betroffen
gewesen. Also sieht man davon noch irgendetwas?
Weißt du auch irgendetwas über die Gebiete jetzt hinter diesem Damm,
die jetzt ja quasi dann entwässert wurden?
Ja, also in Kherson selber das Gute sozusagen ist, dass die Stadt wie so ein paar Meter höher liegt.
Also wenn man zum Fluss kommt, dann geht das immer noch so ein Stück runter.
Das macht so, ich weiß nicht, die letzten 50 Meter oder so geht es immer so ein bisschen bergab.
Und ich denke, das wird die Stadt gerettet haben, weil es ja nicht wie so ein
Tsunami kam, sondern einfach nur, ich weiß nicht, ein, zwei Meter im höchsten Fall angestiegen ist.
Aber weiter nach Osten da, Antonivka und so weiter, da flacht es irgendwo ab.
Und diese Aufnahmen, die man halt gesehen hat von so überschwemmenden Straßen
und so, das war die Ecke eher.
Also sozusagen nicht fährt so eine Stadt direkt, sondern ein bisschen außerhalb,
wo es dünner besiedelt war und zumindest zum Glück,
das ging zwar relativ schnell, es war nicht so ein Tsunami, der die Häuser weggerissen
hat, sondern es stieg halt, sodass die Leute oft noch eine Chance hatten,
so gerade eben zumindest wegzukommen.
Beim Fluss ein bisschen so Sachen.
Wir haben zum Beispiel Gegenden gehabt, wenn man dann Richtung Saporica sich
bewegt, also da, wo dieser große See oder dieses Becken war.
Da sind dann zum Beispiel so Stellen, wo man Boote ins Wasser lassen kann,
also wo so eine Straße endet und so ein kleiner Steg ist.
Und dann ist aber 50 oder 100 Meter gar kein Wasser zu sehen.
Also da merkt man, dass die Dinger so irgendwie nicht da sind, wo sie hingehören.
Das sieht so aus wie zum Teil einfach wie Wüste, weil das wie so ein sandiger
Boden oder sowas ist, also so ein bisschen so Schlamm und Sand.
Und ich war aber überrascht, weil der Fluss in der Mitte breiter war,
als ich dachte. So auf den Satellitenbildern dachte ich immer,
das ist wie so ein Rinnsaal.
Das waren zum Teil aber schon, weiß ich nicht, 50 Meter oder breiter,
wahrscheinlich da, wo es nicht so tief war oder so.
Aber es ist, und es ist so ein bisschen schlammig einfach,
Besonders sieht man es in Saporica,
da gab es halt so Beachbars und sowas in der Art oder so Anleger,
die rausgingen, wo die Anlagen mal drauf standen und das steht jetzt quasi im
Nichts oder die hatten wie so kleine Ausflugsschiffe vielleicht für 100 Leute
oder so, die so ein bisschen den Fluss hoch und runter gefahren sind.
Und die stehen jetzt zum Teil quasi neben Wohnhäusern, weil da wie so ein Flussarm
hinging, wo die angebunden waren.
Aber dieser Flussarm ist trocken. Und inzwischen, weil das ja,
ich glaube, zweieinhalb Jahre oder so her ist, wächst da auch irgendein Grünzeug.
Das heißt, das sieht aus, als hätte da jemand ein Schiff auf einer Wiese vergessen oder so.
Also weil es immer weniger zu erkennen ist, wie das mal aussah.
Und also es ist ein bisschen komisch, Weil man sieht nicht auf den ersten Blick, dass was fehlt.
Also es ist nicht so, dass man da hinkommt und sofort sagt, oh hier fehlt der Fluss.
Sondern erst wenn man guckt, denkt man, warum parkt man da ein Boot?
Und warum ist das Strandcafé 200 Meter vom Fluss weg?
Und warum ist da so ein Weg, wie so eine Seebrücke, die aber einfach auf dem Trockenen steht?
Und dann sieht man so nach und nach, was da irgendwie nicht mehr zusammenpasst.
Bis vor einer Weile war es auch auf Google Maps so, dass man je nach Zoom-Level
den Fluss oder das Ausgetrocknete gesehen hat.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch geht, aber es war ganz lustig.
Umso näher man ranfliegt, umso älter werden dann die Daten, weil du natürlich
quasi jetzt nur den Top-Level-Satelliten überflug hast.
Aber alles, was quasi aus Flugzeugen vielleicht generiert wurde,
das existiert natürlich jetzt nicht aktuell.
Ganz spannend, weil man es damit ganz gut so hin und her schalten konnte.
Aber man merkt dann, wenn man vor Ort ist, man sieht das überraschend wenig
so im Alltag. Also wenn man halt darauf achtet, klar sieht man es.
Aber es fällt nicht so sehr auf, weil da eh viele so Felder und Wald und Büsche und so sind.
Und wenn man halt nicht auf die Details achtet, merkt man es nicht.
Und auch dadurch, dass das halt jetzt ein paar Jahren sich so quasi eingebürgert hat oder so.
Es ist ja auch das Atomkraftwerk gegenüber Ennahoda, was man immer Saporitscher Atomkraftwerk nennt.
Und das ist ja auch seit quasi Kriegsbeginn von den Russen besetzt.
Und da hat man sich auch irgendwie dran gewöhnt.
Und dass die Russen jetzt, ich glaube an der engsten Stelle 20,
30 Kilometer, also so waren die Drohneinschläge von Saporitscha weg und die
Front ist so eine Stunde mit dem Auto.
Also es ist ganz viel, wo man inzwischen merkt, die Leute haben sich einfach dran gewöhnt.
Also die gehen ins Café, die gehen arbeiten und alles und sagen,
ja, hier ist Krieg, aber ist jetzt halt schon seit ein paar Jahren.
Also was soll ich machen? Soll ich jetzt drei Jahre im Keller sitzen?
Und Kherson ist halt echt leer, aber in Odessa und Saporica hat man so ganz
normales Straßen- und Stadtleben.
Also da merkt man nicht, dass da Leute fehlen. Dann hat man halt zwischendurch
den Alarm und dann gibt es auch Einschläge und dann geht das Leben einfach weiter.
Also es ist so, es ist wirklich komisch, weil am Anfang, wenn es irgendwie Alarm
gab, sind alle gerannt und Panik und inzwischen sagt man, ja du,
ich kann nicht jedes Mal losrennen, nur weil ein Alarm kommt.
Okay, also deine Reise in die Ukraine war dann gezielt und eher kurz.
Und danach bist du ja nach Kurdistan gefahren.
Genau.
Das hat man auch nochmal erwähnt, weil ja nun Kurdistan Teil,
also ein nicht ganz zu vernachlässigender Teil des gesamten Nahostkonflikts
immer war und wahrscheinlich auch noch eine Weile bleiben wird.
Und Kurdistan ja vor allem, ich kann an der Stelle auch nur nochmal erinnern,
wir hatten vor längerer Zeit irgendwann mal auch eine gezielte Sendung über
Kurdistan gemacht im Rahmen von CAE,
wo wir mal diese ganze Geschichte und Zusammenhänge und Kultur und so weiter erläutert haben.
Aber was man auf jeden Fall immer im Kopf haben sollte, es gibt halt Kurdistan, gibt es halt im Irak.
Das ist, sagen wir mal, heutzutage so das Kern Kurdistan, wo es sich auch so
nennt und weitgehend auch autonom schaltet und waltet.
Es gibt kurdische Gebiete im angrenzenden iranischen Bereich,
es gibt kurdische Gebiete im
angrenzenden syrischen Bereich und natürlich auch im türkischen Bereich.
Die haben alle auch sehr unterschiedliche Arten und Weisen mitzumischen im Weltgeschehen.
Das kann man nicht alles unter einen Begriff stellen.
Kurdistan im Irak mit der Hauptstadt
Erbil ist ein recht lebendiger und weitgehend befriedeter Bereich.
Da bist du ja nun oft gewesen, jetzt ein weiteres Mal, weil du was mitzubringen hattest.
Genau, im Januar, es war auch ein bisschen lustig, ich war auf dem Rückweg aus
der Ukraine und ein Freund rief mich an und irgendwie, es war so an der Grenze,
wo man so zwischen den Handynetzen hängt und die Verbindung war nicht gut und
er fragte, ob ich irgendwie nach Kurdistan will, weil wir müssen da hin.
Und ich hatte ihm dann nur so eine Textnachricht geschickt und gesagt,
du, ich verstehe dich nicht gut, aber irgendwie, ich habe verstanden,
du willst Darlings in den Iran bringen.
Er sagt, okay, sag mir, wann und wo ich sein muss und dann bin ich dabei.
Er sagte nur später, als wir dann uns getroffen hatten, das war ganz lustig,
weil er ungefähr 20 Leute gefragt hat und die alle lang und breit erklärt haben,
warum sie gerne würden, aber es nicht geht.
Er sagt, der Einzige, den er nicht richtig erreicht hat, schreibt nur zurück,
wann und wo muss ich sein. Ich sagte, okay, der ist der Richtige.
Es war ein bisschen verworren. Der ist selber Jeside, dessen Familie aus Kurdistan,
Irak kommt, aber er ist in Deutschland aufgewachsen und wir kennen uns ewig.
Und der hat oft echt verrückte Ideen oder echt komische Ideen,
aber der zieht die auch durch oder der versucht, die durchzuziehen.
Der hat da auch vor mehr als zehn Jahren gesagt, er will ein Waisenhaus bauen
für die ganzen Kinder, deren Eltern vom IS umgebracht wurden.
Da habe ich auch gesagt, ja, viel Erfolg. Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht,
wo man da anfängt. Und dann hat er das gemacht.
Dann hat er alle Kinder vermittelt und dann hat er eine Schule gebaut,
wo ich dachte, okay, also der ist, wenn man den im Alltag erlebt, ist er...
Also er hat eine Menge Ideen und wenn man nicht wüsste, dass er die regelmäßig
umsetzt, würde man sagen, der hat aber eine Menge dämlicher Ideen, wie soll das gehen?
Nur deswegen war mir klar, wenn der sagt, wir bringen die Dinger in den Iran,
dann bringen wir die Dinger in den Iran oder finden einen, der sie rüberträgt.
Also deswegen habe ich nur gesagt, ja, ab geht's. Weil bei allen anderen hätte
ich wahrscheinlich gesagt, du melde dich, wenn du eine Idee hast wie.
Sollten wir vielleicht nochmal den historischen Kontext auch nochmal setzen.
Also wir hatten ja im Dezember diesen ersten Angriff Israels und der USA auf den Iran.
Dann ging das ja so für zwölf Tage, das Bombardement. Da ist Iran so ein bisschen
auf dem linken Fuß erwischt worden.
In der Folge gab es dann ein paar Wochen später auch noch mal wieder ein Aufruhr
in den Städten, wo alle dann schon wieder dachten, jetzt geht es los,
jetzt wird das Regime gestürzt.
Kam natürlich dann wieder anders und ich denke, wir machen uns auch ein bisschen
falsche Vorstellungen davon, wie sicher dieses Regime dort im Sattel sitzt.
In der Folge wurden nach Schätzungen, Berichten, was auch immer,
Quellen, mehrere 10.000 Leute umgebracht, um diesen Aufruhr zu stoppen,
was damit natürlich dann auch gelang und dann war es mal wieder ein bisschen Ruhe.
Aber jetzt ist natürlich der Kurdistan-Bereich im Iran, ist ja auch nicht der
einzige nicht-persische Bereich, sondern je nachdem wohin man schaut,
also an allen Ecken und Enden.
Es gibt da eine aserbaidhanische Community im Norden, es gibt dann sehr stark
mit Pakistan verbundene im Osten etc.
Also es ist auch ein Vielvölkerstaat und die Kurden sind natürlich immer so
ein bisschen auch bekannt dafür, schnell mal Ärger machen zu wollen,
weil die natürlich mit den Persern da auch nicht klarkommen und dem iranischen Regime.
Ich denke auch diese...
Protestwelle vor einigen Jahren ging ja auch von dort aus.
Genau.
Genau. Und Kommunikation ist ja dann auch abgeschaltet worden.
Also Iran kontrolliert das Internet so krass, dass er halt auch komplett abschalten
wie derzeit wieder und hat, selbst wenn es Zugang gibt zum Netz, starke Filter am Start.
Und meines Wissens haben die auch so diverse Maßnahmen, um auch den Betrieb
von Starlink-Terminals einzuschränken.
Genau, und das war ein wichtiger Punkt. Also wir hatten früher,
das ist auch lange her, aber mit Leuten zu tun, die sozusagen WiFi-Longshot-Equipment
an die Grenze gebracht haben, um in den Iran reinzuschießen.
Und dann brauchten die halt auf der anderen Seite aber möglichst unauffälliges
Equipment, um zu antworten, weil wenn man dadurch sucht wird,
also wenn man hier eine Pringles-Antenne bei hat, kann man der Polizei sagen,
was möchtest du denn? Das beweist ja nichts.
Und im Iran ist das mit der Beweislastumkehr eher umgekehrt.
Und das heißt also, die hatten dann verschiedene Ideen, wie man halt Antennen
in Alltagsgegenständen verstecken kann.
Aber die haben auch gesagt, man muss trotzdem auf 10, 15 Kilometer an die Grenze.
Und wenn du 10 Kilometer an der Grenze stehst, bist du immer auffällig.
So, und dann als Darlings kam, war ein wichtiger Punkt, wir haben halt immer
wieder, also wenn man in der Gegend ist, bleibt es nicht aus,
hat man viel mit Ami-Diensten zu tun.
Und die hatten uns gesteckt, dass Darlings dort auch funktionieren,
im Iran auch schon länger.
Also sie wollten nicht genau sagen, seit wann und wie, aber zumindest ließen
sie durchsickern, wenn man die rüberbringt, dann kann die schon einer nutzen.
Und dann hatten wir halt, also der eine Freund, der mich dann angerufen hat,
das Problem war auch, Das war ja nicht groß geplant.
Wir sind dann hier wirklich die Mediamärkte abgeklappert und so und haben alles
Starlings gekauft, die wir in die Finger gekriegt haben.
Und auch so ein lustiges Problem war, wir waren dann halt am Abend,
bevor wir abgeflogen sind, damit wussten dann erst, wie viele Starlings wir
haben und haben dann überlegt, wie gibt man die dann als Gepäck auf?
Also wie packen wir die jetzt um oder lassen wir die in den Kartons und muss
man die jetzt verstecken oder nicht und was ergibt Sinn?
Dann haben wir halt einfach ein Foto von gemacht und Gemini gefragt,
ey, das ist mein Flugticket und das muss ich verpacken.
Wie verpacke ich das so, dass es in meine Gepäckfreigabe passt?
Dann hat der uns erklärt, wie wir die Stapel mit Gaffer-Tape umwickeln sollen.
Dann haben wir nur nicht dran gedacht, dass es damit so sinngemäß übergroßes Gepäck war.
Also nicht das, was man am normalen Schalter aufgibt, sondern wo man zu dem
Ski- und Golftaschenschalter und so muss.
Dann kamen wir da halt an mit Flugtickets Richtung Irak halt,
mit so irgendwie zwei großen Gaffer-Tape-Knubbeln mit Starlink-Antennen.
Und dann fragte der Deutsche Zoll halt auch, was wir damit genau wollen.
Dann hat er gesagt, es bringt jetzt ja auch nichts, darum rumzureden.
Dann hat er gesagt, wir bringen den Irak und schmuggeln den in den Iran.
Weil ich dachte, es fällt auch keine blöde Ausrede ein, was ich jetzt machen soll.
Dann haben die gesagt, ja, es ist ja hier nicht verboten. Also insofern alles
okay. Sie haben sich nur gewundert, was wir da mit dem ganzen Scheiß wollen.
Ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht, was, ja okay.
Ich meine, was soll man denn sonst erzählen? Es gibt keine schlüssige Geschichte.
Mal mit dem Kram anzeigen.
Und naja, dann sind wir halt rüber. Und es war aber immer noch nicht so 100%
klar, wo wir jetzt Werdi genau wie rüberbringt.
Und der Freund von mir sagte, so wie immer in Kurdistan, er kennt einen,
der einen kennt, der einen kennt, der einen kennt, der es aber ganz sicher rüberbringen kann.
Er sagt, okay. Das Hauptproblem ist halt immer,
Wenn man einen kennt, dann muss man immer zu dem anderen fahren,
den er kennt und Tee trinken und sich vorstellen und was erzählen.
Und dann sagt der einem, wer der Nächste in der Kette ist, weil die einen immer kennenlernen wollen.
Das heißt, wir sind dann nach Kurdistan geflogen, sind da mit diesem Stapel
Dinger eingereist und habe dann gesagt, lass uns schnell machen,
weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, ob das jetzt ein Nachmittag oder eine Woche ist,
wie viele Leute wir besuchen müssen, bis wir den haben, der weiß, wie es rüber geht.
Das war auch ein bisschen obskur, weil der eine, den wir gefragt haben,
sagt, wollt ihr mit rüber oder nur die Dinger?
Ich auch dachte, das ist eine interessante Frage.
So, aus Interesse?
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das so schlau ist.
Ich glaube, das könnte echt eine lebensverkürzende Maßnahme sein,
wenn die einem im Iran mit so einem Stapel Starlings aufgreifen,
auch wenn man Deutscher ist.
Ja und dann haben wir uns da durchgehangelt von einem zum nächsten zum nächsten
zum nächsten und der letzte Herr in der Kette war auch ganz lustig,
weil es ging so ein bisschen drum ihr wollt was schmuggeln im Sinne von was
Illegales oder was Legales,
also es geht ja um Schmuggeln, sagt Narba geht es um sowas wie Drogen und Waffen,
weil da wollen wir nichts mit zu tun haben, sagt nee nee das fand ich auch interessant
die haben gesagt Drogen, gar nicht, Waffen, kommt vielleicht drauf an für wen,
Starlings, klar Ja, also so, ne.
Und das war auch so, auch rein geografisch, immer jeder, an den wir weitergereicht
wurden, war dichter an der iranischen Grenze.
Und der letzte war dann echt nur noch so Kilometer zur Grenze.
Und das war dann derjenige, der auch wirklich die Dinger, also tatsächlich echt
einfach auf den Esel lädt und rüberbringt, so.
Und dem haben wir das dann erklärt und er sagt, okay, aber wohin soll das dann
zugestellt werden auf der anderen Seite?
Das ist natürlich auch eine gute Frage, weil so blöd es ist,
aber das hatte ich jetzt nicht so genau durchdacht.
Also so an welche Postadresse möchten Sie es gerne haben da drüben?
Ich hatte auch gesagt, naja, meine Idee war, sagt er ja, warte,
ich habe da so, ich kenne da wen, der könnte da hilfreich sein.
Und brachte uns dann zu so einem Camp von den iranischen Rebellen in den Bergen
und sagte, die Jungs, die sind da drüben aktiv.
Also im Irak.
Im Irak noch so auf dem letzten Meter. Also das, was man jetzt auch in den Nachrichten
ab und zu so sieht, dass da irgendwelche Camps bombardiert wurden an der Grenze.
Sogar das Camp, in dem wir waren, ist dann zwei Wochen später bombardiert worden vom Iran.
Also und da waren dann so, also was man so allgemein wie so als Gebellen oder so bezeichnen würde.
Da gibt es dann natürlich wieder zig Gruppen und die sind alle ein bisschen anders.
Und das allerlustigste daran war, dass der eine davon dann drauf kam,
dass er und ich einen gemeinsamen Bekannten hatten auch noch in Kurdistan.
Ich sagte, gut, das heißt, wir haben da eine Vertrauensbasis sozusagen.
Und der hat dann gesagt, ja, Sie können die gerne mit rübernehmen und das Netzwerk,
was Sie dann da aufbauen, auch mit allen anderen teilen.
Und eine damals relevante Sache, deswegen konnten wir am Anfang nicht erzählen,
wo genau, wie wir was gemacht haben, weil halt alle Details unglaublich relevant
waren und inzwischen gar nicht mehr.
Und ein Punkt war, wir haben denen die Starlings dann gezeigt und die guckten
total komisch. Also das hätten sie noch nie so ein Ding gesehen.
Dann dachte ich, die wohnen ja auf einem Berg mit Eseln, aber die leben nicht
hinter dem Mond. Die werden doch schon mal einen Starling gesehen haben.
Und dann sagten die die Dinger, sagten ja oder so, sagten die, sind die nicht größer?
Sagten, ja, das sind halt die Minis, die sind klein. Moment mal,
was habt ihr denn bisher rübergetragen?
Und dann kamen wir drauf, dass die bisher nur die großen, also die zweite Generation,
sagten, warte, warte, warte.
Kennt ihr irgendeinen da drüben, weil der Unterschied ist ja,
die alten sind so groß wie wie ein Röhrenfernseher oder was weiß ich,
was man als Größenvergleich nimmt.
Und die, die wir bei hatten, halt wie so ein Schulatlas.
Nur, dass man sich das so vorstellen kann.
Und sagt, nee, haben sie drüben noch nicht gesehen. Er sagt,
oh, das heißt, wir posten jetzt keine Fotos von diesen Dingern,
weil das ein Informationsvorteil wäre, den wir überhaupt nicht vorher im Blick
hatten. Weil ich dachte, die nutzen da Starlink Minis.
Und dann haben die gesagt, das ist ja total einfach zu verstecken.
Das macht die Sache viel leichter.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, hier sind auch USB-Adapter dabei.
Also ihr könnt die Dinger mit einer Powerbank betreiben. Was halt auch ein massiver Unterschied ist.
Also im Verstecken, im Transportieren.
Die sagten auch, in dem kurdischen Gebiet ist es auch nochmal anders.
Da kommen die Revolutionsgarden nicht einfach vorbei und durchsuchen so ein Haus.
Also es passiert mal. Aber die wissen auch, dass sie da nicht,
also sie haben da so ein bisschen die Macht, aber es ist eher wie so eine Balance.
Also wenn du als iranischer Polizist das falsche kurdische Haus durchsuchst,
kann es auch sein, dass du da ein Problem hast und das so ein bisschen hin und
her pendelt, bevor klar ist, wer der Stärkere ist.
Und deswegen können die da so ein bisschen freier operieren oder ein bisschen
auch mal so ein paar Starlings verteilen und wissen, das geht.
Das abgefahrenste Foto, was wir nachher zurückgeliefert bekommen haben,
da haben die auch gesagt, das Foto zeigen dürfen wir erst, wenn der Krieg vorbei
ist, weil es halt ein Location-Shot ist.
Das ist einer unserer Starlings mit unserem Starlink-Aufkleber vor einem Büro
der Revolutionsgarden fotografiert, also mit der Flagge draußen.
Die haben gesagt, nur fürs Archiv, Aber welche Stadt das genau ist,
wenn die Sache rum ist, dürft ihr es posten. Aber wo ich dachte, okay, Respekt.
Am Ende war das aus unserer Sicht dann überraschend unspektakulär.
Wir haben halt Unmengen Tee getrunken und Baklava gegessen und Hände geschüttelt,
damit immer jeder wusste, wer sind wir, worum geht es und vertraute uns.
Und am Ende haben die die rübergenommen und sagten aber, wir waren also zu der
Zeit natürlich nicht die einzigen, die die Idee hatten.
Da sind wohl eine Menge rübergekommen.
Ein anderes Problem war halt, dass es hieß, dass der Iran die stört.
Und das ging einfach so, dass die halt in erster Linie GPS-Jamming oder Spoofing betrieben haben.
Die Starlings aber halt das GPS-Signal brauchen, um sich auszurichten,
also um zu wissen, wo sind sie und wo ist der Satellit.
Und da haben wir dann auch einfach mit SpaceX den Kontakt gesucht und gesagt, was machen wir da?
Und SpaceX hat sowas wie die Support-Hotline für Regime-Problemzonen und die sagten, pass mal auf.
Natürlich haben wir das kommen sehen und da gibt es ein ganz tolles Feature,
was ihr hier in so einem Hidden Menu aktivieren müsst und dann macht das ein
bisschen Magie und dann geht das Ding weiter.
Dann haben wir gesagt, okay, aber wie genau, also was heißt das?
Also die haben gesagt, setz den Haken und frag nicht blöd, so.
Und dann funktioniert das Ding weiter. Und dann sagt, okay, es klingt komisch.
Haben den Kurden das erklärt und gesagt, ja, die Dinger funktionieren, trotz GPS-Boofing.
Auf welche, ich meine, du brauchst ja normalerweise auch einen bezahlten Account,
damit diese Stylings funktionieren?
Lustigerweise nicht im Iran. Du klappst die auf und die haben Netz. Ohne irgendwas.
Also die haben, das ist auch, das finde ich immer so ein bisschen traurig,
Musk ist ja echt nicht mehr, sagen wir moralisch und politisch,
nicht mehr der engste Freund, um es mal so zu formulieren.
Aber was die Sache angeht, dachte ich Respekt. Die haben sozusagen extra Features
für solche Zonen, dass sie Spoofing umgehen und nicht mal, dass man nicht zahlt,
sondern du brauchst halt nicht mal einen Account.
Also du machst das Ding an und ohne, dass du es mit der App oder so verbindest,
geht das WiFi an und es läuft.
Wo ich dachte so, Respekt. Also vorher war es so, dass man einen Account brauchte,
den man vorher angelegt hat und jetzt seit Dezember oder Januar brauchst du nicht mal mehr den.
Ja, ich schaue ja auch gerade auf so eine inoffizielle Starlink-Map.
Ich bin mir gerade nicht so sicher, ob ich das alles richtig verstehe,
aber das klassische Starlink, als es gestartet ist, funktioniert ja primär über so Downlinks.
Also es gibt so Orte, wohin dann quasi, also man kann sich den Satelliten oben
fast so wie so ein Spiegel vorstellen, wenn ich da halt hochfunke,
dann wird mein Signal mehr oder weniger oder meine Daten werden dann irgendwo
an einen stationären Ort übertragen und von dort geht es halt ins Netz.
In der Region gibt es aber irgendwie gar nicht so viele oder zumindest nicht
so viele Dokumentierte.
Ja, es ist natürlich auch im Irak, angeblich geht Starlink im Irak nicht,
also weil es nicht freigeschaltet ist oder wie das heißt, aber es auch,
man kann sie nur nicht dort als,
Heimatort anmelden, aber wenn man die im Roaming-Modus mitbringt oder also wenn
man den voraktiviert hat, geht der auch im Irak.
In Syrien meine ich nicht, also weil die haben ja auch so Zonen,
wo sie nicht funktionieren wegen politischen Gründen halt.
Und Irak war wohl so So wie der Irak will es nicht, aber es ist uns jetzt auch
nicht so wichtig mit den Freunden zu sein. Also geht es im Roaming-Modus.
Und Iran war halt, ich meine am Anfang, also vor zwei Jahren oder drei Jahren.
Noch so, dass es wirklich nicht ging.
Und irgendwann haben sie es dann offensichtlich so...
Freigegeben oder so. Mir konnte aber niemand genau sagen, wann und wie.
Und dann haben sie es jetzt halt seit diesem Jahr auch noch kostenlos und ohne
Account gemacht. Also das waren so die Eskalationsstufen quasi, die sie da hatten.
Gut. Mittlerweile gibt es ja auch die neue Generation der Starlink-Satelliten, die mit anderen,
die so Mesh oder Ja, die machen da so Laserkommunikation zwischen den einzelnen
Satelliten und können das dann so durchreichen, bis es dann eben einen Satelliten erreicht,
der die Daten dann wiederum an einen Downlink übergeben kann.
Also man muss den ja quasi dann auch sehen.
Naja, okay, gut. Also mit anderen Worten, Starlink Terminals sind im Iran ein Thema.
Wir sind ja jetzt im Januar. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt war, wie schon erwähnt,
der eine Angriff auf den Iran abgeschlossen, diese Phase.
Was ist denn dein eindruck gewesen wie die gesamtsituation dort mit dem iran
dort in der region so bewertet wird.
Also der fast alle die ich da treffe sagen das volk ist super und regime ist
halt ein problem was auch nicht klar ist weil es gibt auch regime wo es volk
trotzdem scheiße ist also es ist ja nicht nicht zwangsläufig es gibt ja auch
regime die soliden rückhalt in der bevölkerung haben und ja mal so mal so.
Und im Iran ist aber schon ein größerer Unterschied, oder zumindest bei weiten
Teilen der Bevölkerung.
Das war auch diese Phase, als es hieß, aber jetzt lehnen die sich auf und dann
irgendwie jetzt kommt die Revolution, was die Leute ja alle paar Jahre zum Iran
erzählen, aber auch große Demos und alles. Das ist noch keine Revolution.
Man muss ja überlegen, da wohnen, ich glaube, 80, 90 Millionen Menschen.
Also es ist ein Riesenland.
Selbst wenn da 100.000 Leute demonstrieren, dann ist das für so ein Regime viel.
Aber mit 100.000 Leuten übernimmst du ein Land nicht, was riesig ist.
Und vor allem nicht, so leid es
mir tut, aber mit 100.000 friedlichen Demonstranten killst du kein Regime.
Man sieht ja jetzt, wie viel Bomben und Hightech-Kram draufgeworfen wird.
Und auch das reicht bisher nicht.
Also das war so der Punkt, wo ich immer gesagt habe, ich wünsche es denen,
aber bleibt mal realistisch, Leute. Da passiert jetzt erst mal gar nichts.
Und was man noch bedenken muss, was die im Kopf haben, 1991,
als Saddam quasi gestürzt werden sollte,
hieß es, hey, Kurden im Irak, lehnt euch auf, wir helfen euch,
jetzt kommt die Revolution, oh, sorry, wir haben einen Deal mit Saddam gemacht, viel Glück euch, ne?
Und da denkt seitdem jeder in der Gegend dran. Und ich glaube,
deswegen ist selbst jetzt, wo die Angriffe so stark sind, die Bevölkerung immer
noch so vorsichtig im Iran, weil die sagen, ja, ja, wir erinnern uns alle an 91 nebenan.
Ich will hier nicht am Baum hängen, wenn in einem Monat das Regime dann doch
ein Deal mit Trump macht oder so.
Und das ist glaube ich der Hauptpunkt, weil da gibt es auch,
als es jetzt hieß, die kurdischen bewaffneten Kräfte, ob die da nicht das Regime
stürzen, denken, nee, das ist auch so, die Kurden leben halt sozusagen am Rand
des Iran Richtung Irak, also da ist der Schwerpunkt.
Was die im Kern wollen, ist in Ruhe gelassen werden. Das heißt,
selbst wenn das Regime weiter da ist und die lassen die Kurden einfach in Ruhe
leben, dann ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass die was gegen das Regime machen,
weil die sagen, warum ins Hornissen-Nest stechen?
Du willst in Ruhe leben, das ist dein Ziel.
Und auch wenn man alle bewaffneten kurdischen Kräfte da zusammennimmt,
das ist ein bisschen unklar, aber dann reden wir von 3000 bis 5000 Leuten,
die Kalaschnikows und Pickups haben.
Ich denke, man sieht auch gerade, dass das nicht reicht, um so ein Regime zu stürzen.
Also was die halt machen ist, die wollen diese bewaffneten Kräfte haben,
um dem Iran klar zu zeigen, hier ist unsere Gegend.
Und wenn ihr uns nervt, dann geht das nicht gut.
Also zumindest wir haben ein bisschen Gegenwehr. Aber es geht nur um so wie
einen Hauch von der Machtbalance erhalten.
Da geht es nicht darum, groß was umzustürzen oder zu ändern.
Das klappt überhaupt nicht.
Und ein anderes Problem ist dadurch, dass die Kommunikation so schlecht ist,
wie viele Menschen stehen denn hinterm Regime im Iran?
Und das kann man fast nicht sagen. Also es ist halt wie so ein Krebsgeschwür
und die in der Mitte, die werden linientreu sein.
Also so wie es hier halt in der DDR war oder wie es in anderen Regimen war.
Aber wie viele sind jetzt Mitläufer, wie viele sind am Rand, wie viele dagegen?
Unglaublich schwierig. Und dazu nur eine spannende Sache. Hitler hatte damals
gesagt, er braucht ein Prozent der Bevölkerung, die solide hinter ihm stehen
und dann kann er sich auf den Weg machen, die Macht zu übernehmen.
Und interessanterweise, als er ungefähr anderthalb Prozent der Leute fest hinter
sich hatte, ging das auch los, dass sie auf dem Weg zur Macht waren.
Also plus eine Menge anderer Faktoren, klar.
Aber das war ein überraschend geringer Wert, mit dem er da anfing.
Deswegen im Iran, wenn wir mal von ausgehen, dass irgendwas zwischen 10 und
20 Prozent wirklich linientreu im Regime sind, sagt man, das klingt erstmal
wenig, aber so wenig ist es auch nicht.
Also so, das ist, ja, und ich meine, die haben jetzt 50 Jahre gehabt, sich da.
Richtig einzugraben und das
ist ja auch nicht so ein zentral verwaltetes Regime, also eben nicht wie,
das ZK der SED oder so, die um den Tisch sitzen, sondern diese verschiedenen Milizen und Armee und,
Revolutionsgarden und dies und das und es sind Und so viele Gruppen,
Fred Pleitgen, der CNN-Journalist, der jetzt auch Anfang März im Iran war für vier Tage,
hatte auch gesagt, sie sind einmal auf einer Straße, ich glaube von fünf verschiedenen
Sicherheitsbehörden hintereinander kontrolliert worden, die da so konkurrierend agieren.
Und das sind halt auch so Sachen, das ist, ich glaube, es fängt damit an,
dass die allermeisten Menschen den Iran nicht im Ansatz verstehen,
also wie die Sicherheitsbehörden funktionieren, wie das Regime funktionieren
und dann immer von, weiß ich nicht, so diese Hollywood-Perspektive haben auf,
du brauchst zwei Actionhelden und die stürzen das Regime, wo man sagt,
nee, nee, das ist im echten Leben leider nicht so.
Also ich sehe auch jetzt nicht, dass das Regime weg ist.
Also wenn jetzt Amis und Israelis rausgehen, dann ist es halt irgendwie geschwächt
und dann haben die ein paar Anpassungsprobleme und dann haben die irgendeinen Schaden.
Aber bisher gibt es ja niemanden, der daran zweifelt, dass die die Macht im Land haben.
Und was noch dazu kommt, Religion spielt hier auch noch eine große Rolle und
der Ayatollah Ramine mag im Westen keinen besonders guten Ruf haben, zu Recht,
aber für die ist er dann halt quasi so der Papst und jetzt haben die Amerikaner
quasi ihren Papst umgebracht und das finden die auch nicht lustig.
Also die Radikalisierung, die das jetzt wiederum nochmal verstärkt,
die wird eher dazu beitragen,
vielleicht sogar auch dieses Regime weiter zu festigen, weil die können ja jetzt
einfach sagen, ja guck mal hier, so sind die Amerikaner, die sollen euch befreien irgendwie.
Das, was wir euch immer erzählt haben über die Amerikaner, so jetzt stimmt's.
Genau, jetzt könnt ihr live dabei zuschauen. Naja, okay, gut.
Also das mal so als Blick, das war ja noch bevor der aktuelle Iran-Krieg losgegangen
ist, bis dann wieder zurück nach Deutschland.
Und dann gab es ja dann erstmal einen ganz anderen Termin, denn es jährte sich
wieder einmal der Angriff, also die Großinvasion Russlands auf die Ukraine.
Man muss ja mal sagen, der Krieg hat ja schon 2014 begonnen, aber der 24.
Februar 2022 war halt einfach der Beginn der aktuellen Auseinandersetzung über
das gesamte Gebiet der Ukraine hinweg.
Und wir hatten es glaube ich auch schon erwähnt, als du das letzte Mal hier warst,
dass du im Rahmen deines Museums, dem Berlin Story Bunker, der eigentlich eine
Ausstellung über Nationalsozialismus ist, Hitler im Fokus hat,
auch einen weiteren Bereich klar gemacht hast, um dort eine Ausstellung zur Ukraine zu machen.
Da war das aber quasi noch geheim und jetzt ist es offiziell und die offizielle
Eröffnung war eben an diesem 24.
Februar. Ich war leider in Südafrika, deswegen konnte ich nicht teilnehmen,
aber andere Leute haben teilgenommen.
Ja genau, wir hatten halt überlegt, zum einen, also die Ausstellung ist überschaubar
groß, die hat so 300 Quadratmeter, weil wir halt noch mitten im Konflikt sind.
Und es halt sehr schwierig ist sich zu überlegen, wie, also wenn die Sache rum
ist, möchte ich auch dazu eine große Ausstellung bauen. Aber wann ist es rum
und was kommt noch an Kapiteln? Keine Ahnung.
Und auf der anderen Seite, weil es aber schon so viel Material gibt und wir
immer so viel zu erzählen haben, dazu wollten wir halt zumindest eine Sonderausstellung
machen, die eben wie so ein Snapshot vom jetzigen Stand ist.
Und dann war der Punkt, die Ausstellung machen ist eine Sache,
dass es Leute mitbekommen ist eine andere Sache.
Und da du in Südafrika warst, musste ich also auf die zweite Garde zurückgreifen,
wie CNN, Reuters, AP und so weiter.
Die Amateure.
Ja genau, deine Praktikanten im Prinzip. Und für die muss man ja was haben.
Und dieses Museum an dem Tag ist ein Baustein, aber es reicht nicht.
Und wir haben dann in der Ukraine gefragt, wer könnte da uns unter die Arme greifen.
Und die damalige Vize-Verteidigungsministerin, also die ein halbes Jahr mit
Zelensky im War Room war, als der Krieg losging, Hanna Malja hat gesagt,
naja, da kommt sie gerne.
Dann einer der Sprecher von der 7th Army Corps, das ist so die,
die Pukovsk derzeit verteidigen und sowas machen, die nach NATO-Standards ausgebildet
sind und so einer der modernen Teile der Armee sind. Die sind gekommen.
Dann der Leiter vom Militärhistorischen Museum der Ukraine, mit dem wir sehr viel zu tun haben.
Und eben unsere Freunde aus Rehason.
Am 12. April 2025 ist ein Fahrzeug mit Freunden von uns bombardiert worden.
Und einer ist gestorben. Einer hat schwer verletzt überlebt.
Und das Fahrzeug haben wir in das Museum gebracht. Das ist so ein Fiat Scudo,
also so ein Kastenwagen im Prinzip, mit dem man halt Leute rumfahren kann.
Der ist von oben von einer FPV-Drohne getroffen worden, hat so ein Meter Loch
im Dach und halt alles drinnen zerfetzt und zersplittert.
Wir haben aber nicht nur das Fahrzeug, sondern wir haben auch die Kleidung,
die unser Freund getragen hat, der überlebt hat von dem Tag,
die man da noch sieht mit den Rissen und dem Blut.
Und wir haben halt die Videos von dem Anflug der Drohne auf das Fahrzeug,
von im Fahrzeug und all diese Details.
Also dass man wirklich das von Anfang bis Ende dokumentieren kann und wo ich
auch sagen kann, ich kannte den Wagen schon Monate vorher, ich kannte die Leute,
also da ist nichts, was man relativieren oder in Zweifel ziehen könnte,
so die Story ist glasklar, Kriegsverbrechen von Anfang bis Ende und das ist
sozusagen ein zentrales Element der Ausstellung.
Dann haben wir mehr als 25 russische Drohnen inzwischen da von FPV-Drohnen über
eine Gerbera und so Supercam-Beobachtungsdrohnen, also Drohnen von 30 Zentimeter bis dreieinhalb Meter,
was aber eher so für die Nerds entscheidend ist.
Wir haben aber auch ganz viele Geschichten von den Menschen eben gesammelt.
Es geht los mit, warum flieht man denn oder warum bleibt man denn?
Weil das ja bis heute so Fragen sind, warum bleiben die nicht da und verteidigen ihr Land?
Dann haben wir halt eine Abteilung, die zeigt, weil es ziemlich scheiße da ist zum Teil.
Ja und warum fliehen die nicht? Na, weil das auch scheiße ist.
Also es ist ja nicht, die eine Lösung ist gut und die andere ist schlecht.
Und wir haben halt eine Fluchtgeschichte, die wir erzählen, von Julia,
einer Künstlerin, die in Sevastopol geboren ist.
Also auf der Krim.
Genau, auf der Krim. Und dann 2014, also nachdem die Russen übernommen haben,
fliehen musste mit ihren Kindern.
Und ist dann nach Odessa, um nicht so weit weg zu sein, also zumindest noch
in der Nähe der Krim, musste dann eben 2022 wieder fliehen.
Und hat aber viele Fotos von der Flucht. Und ihre Tochter war acht,
glaube ich, als sie geflohen sind, sieben oder acht.
Und es gibt viele Fotos, weil es kalt war, wo die so eine Mütze und so Winterschuhe trägt.
Und die Mütze und die Winterschuhe hatte sie aber noch und hat uns die auch fürs Museum gegeben.
Das sind halt auch so Dinge, die Geschichte ist schon berührend,
aber für viele Menschen eben dann diese Mütze und die Schuhe so zum Anfassen
davor zu haben, das bewegt die Menschen vielmehr oder das vermittelt vielmehr,
obwohl es ja eigentlich trivial ist.
Es sind halt Kinderschuhe, die hat man tausendmal gesehen, aber in dem Kontext.
Und so haben wir halt versucht, so eine Mischung zu machen aus diesen persönlichen
Geschichten und Elementen, die wir haben, auch Sachen zu Crowdfunding.
Und es ist ja auch in diesem Krieg, so viel Crowdfunding gab es noch nie.
Und so Highlights wie die Selensky-Action-Figur, die wir am Anfang irgendwo
in den USA gefunden haben.
Oder das Kuscheltier von einem Radpanzer, den man an einer Tankstelle crowdfunden konnte.
Also diese bizarren Auswüchse, die Crowdfunding genommen haben.
Dann halt diese persönlichen Geschichten, das Leid, Militärgeschichte und alles
halt so grob zusammengeschoben, dass man so einen Überblick hat.
Ja, und all diese Menschen waren halt zur Eröffnung da und wenn man Presse einlädt,
ist immer die Frage, kommt überhaupt einer?
Und man kann es echt nie sagen und es kommt darauf an, was passiert am Abend davor?
Und wir haben gesagt, boah, Trump, flieg jetzt nicht in den Iran.
So, wenn du jetzt rüber fliegst, dann haben wir morgen keine Presse hier, ne?
War aber nicht so. Und wir hatten, ich glaube, 70 Presseteams da.
Also das Verhältnis von Menge an Journalisten zur Größe des Museums war schon
beeindruckend, weil es fast gesättigt war.
Und wie gesagt, wir hatten CNN da, was für ein Museum in Deutschland schon eine
Messlatte bis heute ist. Wir hatten halt Reuters, Associate Press da,
wir hatten alle großen deutschen Zeitungen da.
Also es war so, wir haben es geschafft, das zu transportieren, was wir wollten.
Wir hatten ja vor drei Jahren, als wir den ersten Jahrestag hatten,
einen abgeschossenen russischen Panzer von der Schlacht um Kiew nach Berlin
gebracht und vor die russische Botschaft gestellt.
Und das Jahr dazwischen hatten wir dann jetzt nichts gemacht,
weil wir gesagt haben, wenn man keine Idee hat, sollte man ja nicht auf Biegen
und Brechen irgendwas machen, Weil das ist auch blöd.
Also nur wenn man eine richtige Idee hat.
Das mit dem Museum war jetzt halt die Idee und dann eben viele Ukrainer einladen
und die zu Wort kommen lassen, dass halt die Medien auch mit denen sprechen.
Also mit dem Soldaten von der Front, mit der Verteidigungsministerin,
mit den zivilen Helfern, mit den Museumsleuten.
Sodass es ein breites Spektrum ist und eigentlich egal, welches Thema man hat
oder was man machen möchte, dass wir nicht sagen, hier ist der eine Experte,
den wir hier haben, sondern du hast hier alles,
einen Querschnitt der Leute und jetzt sprich mit denen, wenn du möchtest.
Und hat zum Glück so funktioniert, wie wir es uns dachten.
Aber nur, weil wir es uns so dachten, heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass es funktioniert.
Also es war überraschend, dass es so aufging und dass wir damit halt eine Menge
Reichweite erzeugen konnten.
Und ja, deswegen war ich zu der Zeit nicht in der Ukraine, was der eigentliche
Plan war, sondern das hatte dann eben Vorrang hier das Nutzen,
um die Geschichte halt weiterzutragen.
Und hat dann die Berichterstattung auch dazu geführt, dass Leute kommen und das besuchen?
Ja, das sind ja auch echt immer so ganz verschiedene Fragen.
Das ist halt auch nur, weil es auf Social Media viel geteilt wurde.
Heißt nicht, dass nur einer vorbeikommt.
Es kommen aber richtig viele vorbei. Also wir haben jetzt derzeit so zwischen
100 und 200 Besuchern am Tag, die dafür kommen.
Was für noch nicht Tourisaison und für Berlin, wo es ja echt eine Menge anderes gibt, viel ist.
Also wirklich viel. Man muss bedenken, es gibt je nachdem, was man zählt,
200 bis 500 Museen in Berlin.
Das sind ja nur die Museen. Es gibt auch Kinos, Clubs und Dönerbuden.
Also je nachdem, wo man Bock drauf hat.
Und ich hatte gehofft, dass überhaupt jemand kommt. Und jetzt ist wirklich ein
ständiger Fluss. Das ist schon schön zu sehen.
Zum einen weniger, aber trotzdem Ukrainer, die hier leben, die es einfach interessiert,
wie zeigen wir das oder wie machen wir das?
Und gerade am Anfang habe ich mit denen auch gesprochen und gesagt,
ist hier irgendwas, was ihr nicht richtig findet oder wo ihr sagt,
das stört mich einfach vom Empfinden her, das ist nicht okay.
Ich denke, das ist immer meine größte Sorge, dass man die Opfer,
denen man eine Stimme geben will, falsch darstellt, weil man es halt nicht richtig sieht.
Die haben gesagt, nö, ist alles gut. Ich sage, okay, das ist schon mal gut.
Also das ist ja so der nicht in so Fettnäppchen treten.
Dann natürlich, jeder hätte gern noch eine bestimmte Geschichte aus seiner Stadt,
seinem Ort, sagen wir, machen wir auch alles, wenn wir das große Museum am Ende
machen. Jetzt noch nicht.
Und ganz viele Leute einfach aus Deutschland, also der Großteil wirklich Deutsche
derzeit, die vorbeikommen.
Also auch so normale Touristen, die die Hauptausstellung angucken, die mit runtergehen.
Aber die, die gezielt kommen, sind wirklich fast alles Deutsche,
aber aus allen Altersgruppen.
Zum Teil sind es Jugendliche, die die Eltern mit hinschleppen,
Erwachsene bis hin zum Rentneralter, alles bei.
Eine Sache noch, Wir wollten...
Wir wollten die Zerstörung zeigen, die angerichtet wird, auch wenn unser eins
das kennt, aber nicht alle.
Und eine Idee war, wir haben ein großes Bild aufgehangen, dreimal vier Meter
von so einem Wohnblock in Kiew, der von einer KH-101 zerbombt wurde,
also wo einfach das Haus fehlt.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, die meisten Leute haben keine Vorstellung,
wie groß so ein Cruise Missile ist und haben die Ukrainer gefragt,
können wir eine KH-101 haben?
Also es ist mal eine nicht explodiert oder so.
Die haben gesagt, was wollt ihr damit? Nein, wir wollen die ausstellen. Ja, könnt ihr haben.
Also sind wir zu dem Amt gegangen, was uns damals den Panzer erlaubt hat zu
importieren und haben gesagt, wir hätten dann eine Idee.
Die haben gesagt, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Wir haben schlechte Erfahrungen mit euch gemacht. Nein.
Also haben wir überlegt, was machen wir?
Wobei schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht, also sie haben schlechte Erfahrungen damit
gemacht, sich gegen alle Pläne von euch zu stellen und dann Recht zu verlieren.
Rechtsstaat. Ich habe nichts Falsches gemacht rechtlich, moralisch auch nicht.
Ihr seid nur schlechte Verlierer.
Zweimal vorm Verwaltungsgericht verloren.
Also nicht du, sondern die. Wir haben auf voller Linie gewonnen.
Wir hatten Dr. Patrick Heinemann.
Seitdem liebe ich Verwaltungsfachanwälte. Ich wusste bisher nicht,
wofür man die braucht und seitdem weiß ich, dafür sind die gut.
Ist übrigens lustig, die Ukrainer konnten sich seinen Namen immer nicht merken
und die nannten ihn nur den Dork Slayer.
Mit dem Titel hat er bestimmt auch nicht gerechnet. Ich habe ihm das gesagt.
Der fand das auch sehr lustig. Genau, und das ging also nicht.
Dann haben wir überlegt, was kann man denn machen? Wie kann man denn so eine
7,5 Meter Cruise Missile bauen?
Nach allen möglichen gescheiterten Versuchen kamen wir drauf,
man könnte das ja 3D drucken.
Okay, jetzt haben wir da, wenn ich so einen Bamboo-Lab-Drucker nehme,
dann muss ich also, ich weiß nicht, 600 Teile drucken über die nächsten fünf Jahre, keine Ahnung.
Also haben wir den größten Drucker, der noch irgendwie bezahlbar war, genommen.
Und jetzt habe ich so einen 1 Kubikmeter 3D-Drucker neben meinem Büro stehen,
der über den kurzen Zeitraum von, ich glaube, sechs Monaten jetzt acht Meter Rakete gedruckt hat.
Mit 400 Kilo Material bisher. Ich hatte vorher keinen 3D-Drucker und ich habe
es mir einfacher vorgestellt.
Aber ich habe gemerkt, wenn man da so 100 Kilo im Monat durchschiebt,
dann gibt es eine Menge Dinge, die kaputt gehen können oder die Verschleiß haben.
Und auch alle Leute, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, die so einen 3D-Drucker
haben, die sagen, ich mache so 10 Kilo im Jahr.
Ich weiß nicht, was ist, wenn man eine halbe Tonne im ersten Jahr fast durch hat.
Aber am Ende es funktioniert. Also es war eine steile Lernkurve, was alles nicht geht.
Und wir sind noch nicht ganz fertig, weil es gab noch Detailprobleme.
Aber im Prinzip jetzt hängen siebeneinhalb Meter an der Wand und jetzt fehlen noch die Flügel.
Aber ja, das sind auch so Kleinigkeiten, die man bei Museen gar nicht bedenkt immer.
Man kriegt halt nicht immer die Exponate, die man will. Und sowas wie,
ich dachte, man holt den 3D-Drucker, druckt auf Drucken und dann ziehe ich da
eine 7,5 Meter Rakete raus. Gemerkt, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Hatten die Ämter eigentlich irgendein Argument, den Import einer nicht mehr
funktionierenden Rakete abzulehnen?
Also grob gesagt wurde uns gesagt, das wird nichts. Und ich glaube,
sie mussten sich dann noch überlegen, wie sie es rechtlich begründet kriegen am Ende.
Ich habe auch gesagt, ich habe einfach keinen Bock mehr auf so einen Scheiß.
Also wenn ich nochmal Langeweile habe, dann hole ich das Ding rüber.
Weil das liegt, wir haben ja so einen, wie soll man sagen, wir haben so einen
Bereich auf einem ehemaligen Atombombensilo, wo so das Schild steht für Enno noch zum Abholen.
Und da sind von einem Heck von einem Hubschrauber über so eine Cruise Missile
bis hin zu Panzerteilen und ich weiß nicht was alles, eine Shahhead,
das wird auch noch lustig, wie kriegen wir die hier rüber?
Wir haben eine Menge Kram da auf so einem Hügel liegen, so viel kannst du mitnehmen.
Und wenn ich mal Zeit habe, dann werden wir das alles durchexerzieren.
Und mein anderes Problem ist, auch wenn mein Bunker theoretisch riesig ist,
ich habe langsam echt ein Platzproblem.
Also ich habe so viele große Drohnen. Wir haben auch inzwischen eine Sammlung
von Scharhead-Motoren und von Cruise-Missile-Triebwerken da.
Wir haben so viele Drohnen, dass wir jetzt angefangen haben,
an andere Museen die zu verleihen, quasi einfach weiterzugeben,
weil, also ein richtig schönes Luxusproblem, aber ja.
Gibt es da noch andere Museen, die sich des Themas annehmen?
Ja, wenige. Ist auch ganz lustig.
Es gibt viele, die es interessiert, die aber sagen, aber sagt niemandem,
dass wir gefragt haben. Also meist so staatliche Museen, die so komplexe Aufsichtsräte
und sonst was haben und die immer aufpassen müssen, dass nicht einer ein bisschen
beleidigt ist. Dann gibt es aber welche...
Zum Beispiel in den Niederlanden gab es jetzt eins, ich habe leider den Namen
vergessen, in Gronau oder Grönau.
Die haben eine Ausstellung über den Krieg und die haben eine Magura V5 da stehen,
also diese Jet-Ski-Drohne,
diese halb getauchte Wasserdrohne, mit der die im Schwarzmeer,
die Ukrainer im Schwarzmeer die Schiffe versenken,
haben die rüberbekommen dafür, wo ich dachte Respekt.
Also das Ding habe ich wirklich noch nicht irgendwo anders gesehen.
Ich glaube, die Holländer haben auch ein etwas anderes Verhältnis zu dem Konflikt als wir.
Genau. Und da ist es halt so, die niederländische Armee hilft denen beim Import.
Und dann geht das sozusagen von Militärtaché zu Militärtaché und dann ist nur
die Frage, wo muss ich stempeln?
Also es ist viel einfacher. Auch mein Panzer steht da vor der Tür,
weil die uns den netterweise abgenommen haben und der jetzt durch die Niederlande tourt.
Die haben jetzt auch angefragt, die brauchen noch einen. Sie haben so viel zu
tun in den Niederlanden, die kommen mit einem Panzer nicht klar.
Das ist halt ganz anders. Und zur Eröffnung der Ausstellung haben sie gesagt,
sie haben so ein paar Drohnen, aber ob ich ihnen noch welche rüberschicken könnte,
er sagt, gerne, gerne, gerne.
Also es gibt, das ist auch so, es ist halt anders. Also in den Niederlanden
der Premierminister und die Bürgermeister bedanken sich jedes Mal,
dass wir ihnen den Panzer leihen.
Und in Deutschland wurden wir ja quasi vom Hof gescheucht damit.
Also es ist, ja man merkt, es ist sehr unterschiedlich, wie man mit dem Thema umgehen kann.
Nur da eben auch, wenn die Armee und die Regierung dahinter steht,
dann ist der Rest eben nicht mehr so kompliziert.
Also es wird nicht der einzige Grund sein, aber was natürlich hier ein dicker
Faktor ist, dass natürlich mal dieses Flugzeug der Malaysia Air von den Russen
in der Ukraine abgeschossen wurde.
Und da waren im Wesentlichen, also die ist glaube ich in Amsterdam gestartet.
Und entsprechend waren halt sehr viele holländische Staatsbürger drin.
Das hat das Land jetzt nicht vergessen. sähe wahrscheinlich auch in Deutschland
anders aus, wenn es in dem Moment ein Flugzeug gewesen wäre,
was aus Frankfurt gekommen ist.
Aber naja, war nun mal nicht so.
Okay, gut. Also schönes Projekt, wer mal nach Berlin kommt.
Link ist natürlich hier in den Shownotes. Ich will jetzt nochmal auf den Iran-Konflikt kommen.
Vier Tage später ging es ja dann auch los und jetzt haben wir halt so eine Situation,
die glaube ich keinen so richtig glücklich macht.
Ich hatte das ja hier mit Pavel in der letzten Sendung auch schon mal durchexerziert
und wir haben so ein bisschen unseren Blick darauf gelegt,
dass im Wesentlichen das Ganze ein sehr großer Fehler zu sein scheint,
den die USA hier begangen haben, weil sie einfach entweder gar keine Experten
gehört haben oder die nicht haben gelten lassen, was die gesagt haben.
Weil natürlich alle gesagt haben, ja Leute in der Ost, habt ihr sie noch alle,
ein größeres Pulverfass kann man kaum anzünden und schon gar nicht so.
Israel spielt in der öffentlichen Diskussion, finde ich, noch eine zu geringe
Rolle, weil die ja letzten Endes die Sache so angetrieben haben.
Und Trump letzten Endes Netanyahu, glaube ich, hier auf den Leim gegangen ist.
Und ich denke auch, dass auch Netanyahu sich jetzt hier verschätzt hat in der Dimension.
Alles quasi, also die in Anführungsstrichen Erfolge, die Israel gehabt hat im
Nachgang der Anschläge vom 7.
Oktober vor drei Jahren, der Gaza-Krieg, die Situation in Syrien,
dass Assad jetzt weg ist.
Also Israel ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht der Gewinner der Entwicklung der letzten Jahre gewesen,
indem sie einfach sich sehr vieler Gegner entweder entledigt haben oder entledigt
wurden und jetzt so ein bisschen als die Kür,
glaube ich, eben den Schlag gegen den Iran gesehen haben, so nach dem Motto,
jetzt nocken wir die auch noch aus und dann ist irgendwie erstmal Ruhe im Karton.
Und offensichtlich hat sich auch Israel dabei übernommen.
Nebenbei gibt es ja jetzt auch noch diesen Konflikt im Libanon weil natürlich
die Hisbollah dann wieder mit,
reingegangen ist und sich nicht zurückhalten konnte und Israel wieder angegriffen hat,
jetzt haben wir dort auch wieder nochmal eine neue
Situation die will ich aber jetzt nicht aufmachen weil das führt jetzt einfach
mal alles viel zu weit am Ende steht aber natürlich Trump jetzt im Mittelpunkt
weil er natürlich überhaupt keine Ahnung hat von diesem ganzen Zusammenhang
und sich jetzt und die ganze Welt mit in diese Situation gerissen hat,
dass der Iran einfach sagt,
ja, mal sehen, wer hier länger die Luft anhalten kann.
Also unsere Leidensbereitschaft ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich groß.
Mal gucken, wie es euch so geht.
Und jetzt im Prinzip alle Golfstaaten, die halt so traditionelle Verbündete
der USA sind, mit in die Krise gezogen hat.
Ich finde die Berichterstattung ein bisschen schwierig.
Teilweise wird es so gesehen, dass die Golfstaaten, die Amerikaner noch...
Unterstützen oder sogar darin bestärken, jetzt nochmal richtig zuzuschlagen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel da dran ist, weil letztlich ist es ja so,
erstmal sowohl das Businessmodell, als auch das, nicht nur das Businessmodell,
sondern das Modell dieser Golfstaaten,
speziell der Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate, aber eben auch Kuwait,
Katar, mit Einschränkung auch Saudi-Arabien, aber vor allem diese kleineren
Golfstaaten, basierte ja immer auf so einem, wir haben das Öl,
wir haben die Verkehrswege,
wir haben viel Geld, wir haben viel Investitionen, wir sind super international.
Und guck mal, wie friedlich das hier ist und legt keinen Dreck auf der Straße,
alles total sicher hier.
Ja, okay, du darfst dir nichts gegen Scheich sagen, aber es war es dann halt
auch im Wesentlichen, macht ihr immer, was ihr wollt und wir laden jetzt mal die ganze Welt ein.
Und ja, jetzt kommt halt auf einmal keiner mehr, weil dort eben Krieg ist.
Aber viel schlimmer ist natürlich die Situation jetzt mit der Straße von Homoos,
wo wir jetzt die Situation haben, dass der Iran einfach sagt so,
Also wer jetzt uns nicht so böse gesonnen ist, der darf hier seine Schiffe auch gerne durchschicken.
Das macht dann zwei Millionen Dollar.
Pro Schiff. Die Kohle brauchen wir ja auch für Reparationen,
weil die USA machen ja hier irgendwie gerade alles kaputt.
Und das ist jetzt so die Situation, in der wir sind.
Und darüber wird ja gerade auch viel diskutiert. Ich wollte aber vor allem jetzt
mal auf diese Perspektive zurückkommen.
Was macht das eben mit dem Konflikt der Ukraine mit den Russen?
Auf der einen Seite sind die Russen ja mit dem Iran gewisser Hinsicht verbündet.
Diese ganzen Drohnen, über die wir jetzt sprechen, das hatte seinen Ursprung
im Iran, die ja jetzt auch zu den Golfstaaten rübergeschickt werden und die
US-Basen dort bedrohen und sie wissen nicht so richtig, was sie dagegen tun sollen.
Trotzdem haben die Russen natürlich so ihr eigenes Problem. Sieht jetzt nicht
so aus, als ob sie den Iran als Verbündete bald verlieren würden.
Aber so richtig helfen können sie, glaube ich, auch nur sehr beschränkt.
Sie können so ein paar Nadelstiche, indem sie so Information-Sharing machen.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen haben sie dort keinen großen Einfluss.
Sie kommen, wie wir vorhin schon gesagt haben, in der Ukraine nicht so richtig voran.
Und obwohl wir jetzt die Situation haben, dass die Ölpreise steigen und damit
ja Russland theoretisch auf einmal von diesem,
60 Dollar Preis, der mehr oder weniger
so break even ist und dann für ihr Schwarzmeeröl gab es noch weniger,
weil das Abholen so teuer war durch die Belagerung durch die ukrainische Armee.
Jetzt durch die Zerstörung der Ostsee-Häfen stehen die Russen halt richtig mit
runtergelassenen Hosen da, weil sie eigentlich mit Ausnahme von so kleinen Ports,
die sie noch ganz im Osten haben,
im Prinzip überhaupt nichts mehr rauskriegen.
Ja und ich meine sozusagen die Flussrichtung von den Pipelines ist halt falsch rum.
Also das ist ja auch, kann man ja nicht mal eben sagen und jetzt schieben wir
mal an die andere Richtung weiter.
Also selbst da wo ja die Pipelines liegen, hilft es nicht, wenn am Ende kein Hafen steht.
Ja und das mit, ja allgemein mit Iran.
Ja, ich finde es eigentlich so ein bisschen ironisch, wie Netanyahu da jetzt sagen kann, hey,
ich habe von Anfang an gesagt, ich will hier nur einen Enthauptungsschlag machen
und was ihr da macht, weiß ich auch nicht, aber es hilft halt nicht,
weil sie natürlich den großen Torn zurückkriegen.
Ja, aber eine spannende Sache war ja, was wir vorhin schon im Prinzip hatten,
jetzt kommen halt so Schahedronen und ähnlich einfacher Kram auf die Golfstaaten
und die haben halt die modernsten Kampfjets und die größte Flugabwehr und sowas
wie Patriot und so und merken halt,
es eskaliert halt nicht gut, selbst wenn du viel Geld hast, also selbst wenn
du es wirtschaftlich eine Weile stemmen kannst, es gibt einfach nicht genug
Raketen und Flugzeuge dafür.
Und ich glaube, es war ja in der ersten Woche, haben die Golfstaaten mehr Patriot-Raketen
verschossen, als die Ukraine für den ganzen Krieg bisher bekommen hat.
Aber es sagte, ach so, es gibt also noch ein paar. Also es war jetzt nie ein,
Versorgungsengpass in dem Sinne, sondern...
Die lagen einfach nur an der falschen Stelle.
Ja, und der, der sie rumliegen hatte, hatte auch nicht die große Lust zu teilen.
Also gibt's ja so, es gibt vom Grippstheater ja so, wie so linke Kinderlieder
und da gibt's eins, da geht's drum, warum denn der eine ein Fahrrad hat und
der andere nicht und warum man nicht mal teilen kann.
Und da dachte ich ja, genau das.
Warum teilen wir nicht mal die Patriot-Raketen?
Der hat, der hat.
Ja, genau. Und das Lustige war ja, so einer der Effekte war,
wie denn plötzlich einfiel, ey, ich habe doch noch Selenskys Handynummer im Telefon.
Und der hatte doch Ideen, wie man Billigdrohnen abwehrt Und wie sie dann ein
paar von den echt guten ukrainischen Antidrohnteams oder die,
die halt Sachen entwickeln, die es erklären können, die es schulen können,
wirklich in Rekordzeit in Riyadh und in Abu Dhabi und sonst wo und in Katar und so hatten.
Und zum einen ja auch, also ich meine, bei Zelensky, bei allem,
was da schief läuft und wie kaputt das Land durch den Krieg ist,
aber da das einzig Richtige gemacht, sofort bei allem sagen,
jo, wir schicken euch die besten Experten, weil reiche Freunde haben,
hat noch niemandem geschadet.
Und das ist, denke ich, auch so ein Punkt. Zum einen, also die Amerikaner schieben
zwar viele Ressourcen in den Nahen Osten, aber zum anderen haben die auch so
ein gigantisches Militär, dass sie trotzdem noch nebenher bei der Ukraine helfen können.
Also das finde ich ja auch so irre, dass es jetzt ja nicht so ist,
dass das, was sie an Information-Sharing und so mit der Ukraine machen,
deswegen zusammenbricht, sondern dass die sagen, naja, das kriegen wir noch
irgendwie so balanciert gerade eben.
Also finde ich auch beeindruckend, gemessen an, was wir so in der EU kennen,
wo irgendwie eine Oderflut und ein E-Werk,
was ausgeht, wäre schon so das Ende von dem, was wir irgendwie gemanagt bekommen
und die kriegen es zumindest bisher hin,
unter der Last nicht zusammenzubrechen, also was ich schon Wahnsinn finde.
Aber ja gut, dafür haben sie halt keine Krankenversicherung.
Man muss ja irgendwas, irgendwo muss man ja Prioritäten setzen.
Aber diese neue, sagen wir mal, neu entdeckte Freundschaft zwischen reichen
Golfstaaten und der Ukraine, da ist ja auch noch nicht so richtig klar,
was jetzt bei rumkommt oder was das Ergebnis ist. Also bis auf so ein paar Fotos
und so, die wir gesehen haben.
Aber da bin ich halt mal gespannt, ob das in den nächsten Monaten zu irgendwelchen
überraschenden Änderungen führt oder was ergibt sich daraus?
Wohin geht das? Also nehmen die Golfstaaten, das war als eine Chance,
irgendwas zusammen zu starten oder fangen die jetzt an, Drohnen zu produzieren
und in die Welt zu verkaufen mit ukrainischem Know-how oder was weiß ich was?
Oder bricht das einfach wieder auseinander, sobald die Sache im Iran vorbei ist?
Also ich kann es in der Ostpolitik und auch von diesen verschiedenen Scheichs
und so, ich finde es immer ein bisschen schwierig einzuschätzen,
in welche Richtung das so im nächsten halben Jahr dann läuft.
Ja, na gut, also ich meine, was ist denn jetzt konkret passiert?
Also Selenskyj hat ja dann sofort so eine Tour gemacht durch alle Golfstaaten hindurch.
Israel hat er nicht besucht auf dieser Reise. In Sybien.
Mit Jolani.
War er auch zusammen? Na gut, die haben ja eh schon so ein gewisses Verhältnis gehabt, weil,
ich denke mal, das erste Drohnen-Know-How, was sie exportiert haben,
war in die Richtung, um dann den Russen dann entsprechend auch Ärger zu machen.
Das hat ja auch funktioniert, auch wenn, glaube ich, diese Militärbasis immer
noch nicht komplett geschlossen ist.
Also geschlossen nicht, aber wie so auf Pause gesetzt oder mit so einer Minimalbesatzung.
Aber es sind auch nicht die letzten Russen weg. Es ist irgendwie...
Unklar noch, was da passiert. Na egal, anderes Thema. Ähm...
Aber was jetzt passiert ist, ich habe keinen kompletten Überblick, aber ich weiß,
dass es zumindest aus VAE und ich meine auch noch aus anderen Golfstaaten jetzt
nicht nur einen Einkauf gab, im Sinne von wir bezahlen euch dafür,
dass ihr jetzt diese Experten macht und eure Drohnen mitbringt und wir kaufen euch mal welche ab,
sondern es gab konkrete Investitionen.
Also die haben sich beteiligt an verschiedenen, ich meine sogar auch Firepoint,
bin mir jetzt gerade nicht ganz so sicher, aber in verschiedenen Unternehmen
und bringen also jetzt Geld mit an.
Das ist natürlich eigentlich für die Ukraine die beste Situation,
weil natürlich die auch daran ein Interesse daran haben, dass diese Investition
sich langfristig auszahlt.
Jetzt nicht unbedingt primär finanziell, sondern vor allem eben dadurch,
dass hier die Weiterentwicklung dieser Abwehrdrohensystem, also mindestens der
Abwehrdrohensysteme, wahrscheinlich nicht nur dieser, aber vor allem dieser,
dass das eben weiter vorangeht und dass es im Idealfall auch noch sehr viel schneller vorangeht.
Dass sowohl die Produktion ausgefahren wird, das findet ja eh derzeit statt,
es werden ja überall Fabriken auch in Europa eröffnet, also Dänemark hatte glaube ich eins, Deutschland.
Dann war noch irgendwas, England glaube ich auch noch,
also es gab so mehrere Standorte und es ist bestimmt noch nicht Schluss mit anderen Worten,
die Ukraine wird demnächst der führende oder ist es wahrscheinlich jetzt schon
der führende Drohnenproduzent in Europa und der Welt Und damit mit dem Geld der Golfstaaten,
die natürlich jetzt einen akuten Bedarf haben und sehen, dass die Amerikaner
allein ihnen Sicherheit nicht gewähren können.
Ist das auf jeden Fall eine extreme Aufwertung der Ukraine.
Also sowohl was jetzt sagen wir mal ihr Standing in diesem militärischen Kontext
der Welt betrifft, das ist ja nicht ganz unwichtig, aber natürlich auch jetzt so,
das will ich nicht moralisch sagen, aber auf dem diplomatischen Parkett ist
das auf jeden Fall ein Pfund.
Weil auch dieser Blick, den die USA und Trump ja immer so befördern möchten
mit so, ja, you don't have the cards, wer seid ihr denn schon?
Ja, so eine Ex-Sowjet-Republik, mir doch egal, Europa, ich weiß sowieso nicht,
wo da oben und unten ist und wie die Staaten heißen.
Für euch interessiert euch doch keiner. Und ich habe so das Gefühl,
dass auch das etwas ist, woraus sich die Ukraine so langsam herausgearbeitet
hat, durch eine konsequente Strategie und jetzt einfach sagt so,
ja, wer hat denn hier irgendwie Ahnung von Modern Warfare?
Wer ist denn das Land, was irgendwie den Russen da Halt bieten kann?
Wer also aufhalten kann?
Wer versteht denn überhaupt Modern Warfare noch?
Und wir können hier irgendwie allem trotzen. Das tun sie ja auch,
das beweisen sie ja auch täglich.
Und ich meine, aus der Warte ist das schon wirklich bold und dass sie jetzt
auch diese Häfen bombardieren, ist ja nicht nur bemerkenswert unter dem Aspekt von,
was du schon erwähnt hast, die Flugabwehr wurde entsprechend dezimiert,
diese Drohnentechnologie, die sie entwickelt haben, ist so effizient,
dass sie es also schaffen, da mit,
einer Armada von Drohnen anzufliegen und denen einfach alle Öltanks um die Ohren
fliegen zu lassen, dass sie da durchkommen, dass sie das schaffen,
Aber dass sie hier mittlerweile auch diesen politischen Cloud haben, zu sagen ...
Weil wir erinnern uns ja noch, dass noch vor einem Jahr war das so,
wenn die Amerikaner gesagt haben, so ah nee,
lass die Russen mal da entfrieden und nicht das Öl, weil dann steigt ja bei
uns der Benzinpreis und dann ist gar nicht gut für die innenpolitische Debatte.
Ist es, glaube ich, der Ukrainer entweder, also einerseits ist es ihnen,
glaube ich, in zunehmendem Maße egal, oder sie müssen nicht mehr so,
oder sie legen nicht mehr so einen Wert da drauf, weil sie halt auch sehen.
Einerseits, es hilft uns nicht, nach dem amerikanischen Lied zu tanzen.
Wir kriegen eh nichts von euch, wir dürfen bestenfalls bei euch kaufen.
Intelligence kriegen wir mittlerweile schon von woanders. Und mit der Ausnahme
dieser Patriots, haben wir eh schon die besseren Antworten, was Militärische
betrifft und ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn wir auch in einen,
Wann weiß ich nicht, aber irgendwann wird auch die Ukraine was Patriot-artiges produzieren.
Da arbeiten die mit Sicherheit schon dran, ihre eigenen Abwehrsysteme für ballistische Angriffe zu haben.
Und vor allem nutzen sie natürlich jetzt diesen Fog of War, wo ja klar ist,
der Benzinpreis steigt.
Wer ist schuld? Trump ist schuld.
Die ganze Welt sieht eigentlich nur das. Und wenn Trump nicht schuld ist,
dann ist vielleicht erstmal nochmal Israel schuld, aber bevor Ukraine schuld
ist, das dringt irgendwie schon gar nicht mehr durch.
Das ist natürlich definitiv eine Aufwertung des Landes und vor allem jetzt auch
ein gutes Cover, um einfach mal den Russen komplett den Geldhahn zuzudrehen.
Ja, und was ich halt auch dachte mit der Ukraine, wenn man ihnen am Anfang richtig
viel Waffen geliefert hätte, also wirklich all in, dann hätte man den Krieg
wahrscheinlich schnell stoppen können.
Genau das, wenn man die Leute nicht durchgehend unterstützt,
entweder sie gehen unter, also je nachdem wie es kippt.
Also so Afghanistan, ich meine, sind jetzt nicht von außen angegriffen worden,
aber in Afghanistan wird die nächsten Jahre nichts Brillantes mehr passieren.
Die dümpeln so vor sich hin, sind vergessen.
Und in der Ukraine halt kippt es zu, dass sie zwar eine echt harte Zeit haben
dadurch, dass sie so am langen Arm immer gehalten wurden und so minimal befördert,
aber genau das, so sie steigen auf und weg.
Und irgendwann kippt es dann eben um, dass man nicht mehr nach Sandhurst geht,
um sich von den Militärexperten in Großbritannien beraten zu lassen,
sondern dann heißt, warum kommt ihr nicht nach Kiew?
Dürfen wir euch vielleicht mal was erklären?
Und auch dieser Punkt mit dem, also im Iran war es ja so, die sind ja so übel
sanktioniert worden wie kaum ein anderes Land und am Anfang klappt das und irgendwann
lernen sie halt mit Leben und
irgendwann kannst du sie mit Sanktionen gar nicht mehr irgendwie ärgern,
weil die sagen, was willst du denn noch sanktionieren, ist ja nichts mehr über.
Denk so auch in der Ukraine, wenn man sie halt immer so am langen Arm lässt,
Irgendwann entwickeln die ihren eigenen Kram und dann haben sie halt das Know-how,
was ja das Hauptproblem ist.
Und dann ist es ihnen egal, ob du sie einen langen Abend verhungern lässt oder nicht.
Also dieses You don't have the cards, also ich denke, das wird sich noch so
drehen im Laufe der nächsten Jahre.
Das ist auch, als es den Sturm aufs Kapitol gab, gab es ja Bilder von Leuten,
die es gestürmt haben, die irgendwo in so einem Tisch von einem Abgeordneten
saßen und ihre Füße da auf den Tisch gelegt haben.
Und eine Zeitung irgendwo in Ostafrika hatte das auf dem Cover mit der Überschrift
Wer ist jetzt die Bananenrepublik?
So in dieser Art erwarte ich das halt irgendwann so in 10 Jahren bei so einem
Trump-Selensky-Treffen, dass der sagt, so hier ist dein Kartenspiel alter Mann.
Der moralische Niedergang der USA, der ist glaube ich mittlerweile schon gar
nicht mehr aufzuhalten.
Und halt auch die Geschwindigkeit, in der die Ukraine jetzt was entwickelt.
Also sozusagen über diesen Hubbel kommen, dass einem keiner hilft.
Und jetzt ist ja so, also das, was die jetzt quasi alle zwei,
drei Monate vorstellen oder auch, da haben wir uns ja auch dran gewöhnt,
dass die die russische Marine im Schwarzen Meer verdrängt haben.
Und dann sagt das, das hätte einem niemand geglaubt. Also es gibt so einen Twitter-Account,
der das immer so zusammenfasst.
Da ist Putin, Der sagte, die Tag 1200 meiner Drei-Tage-Operation,
ein Land ohne Marine hat ein weiteres meiner Kriegsschiffe versenkt.
Man sagt, ja, das fasst halt so zusammen, so wie geht das?
Und ja, also wenn die Nummer in der Ukraine mal vorbei ist und es da irgendwie
halbwegs friedlich ist,
nachdem die die Häuser aufgebaut haben, wird das so explodieren der Rüstungssektor
da, also Tourismus und Rüstung, also so in die beiden Richtungen.
Ich glaube da, also so vor sechs Jahren haben die Deutschen das Land nicht auf
der Landkarte gefunden.
Und dann wird es auch so sein, wollen die dann noch in die EU?
Da sagen die, ach Leute, es läuft ganz okay hier.
Ja gut, ich denke in die EU wollen sie auf jeden Fall und da sollten sie auch
hin und das wird auch stattfinden.
Da muss sich bloß die EU immer erst von ihrem Mini-Putin-Orban, glaube ich, loslösen.
Das ist ja auf einem guten Weg, so wie es aussieht.
Ja, warten wir mal ab. Also in der Woche sind da die Wahlen und das kann schon
noch alles ganz schlimm werden da.
Also wissen wir noch nicht so richtig.
Jetzt haben sie, glaube ich, nochmal irgendeine Nebelkerze gezündet und irgendwelche
Springfallen an der Pipeline und Selensky war es.
Also es ist auch so lächerlich, wie sie mittlerweile vorgehen.
Ich glaube, das ist auch das Gute. Also so ein bisschen wie so typische Propaganda.
Die Leute, die es glauben wollen, die glauben es, aber es ist inzwischen so
schlecht, dass du halt keine neuen mehr mit erreichst.
Ja, das bleibt nur zu hoffen.
Ja, also,
Jetzt wollte ich irgendwie ein Fazit ziehen.
Fragen wir mal so, wie blickst du denn jetzt auf das Kriegsgeschehen in der Ukraine derzeit?
Wie siehst du die Kräfte verteilt? Was ist deine Erwartungshaltung?
Wann ist der Krieg vorbei?
Ja,
aber ich denke so, also zum einen man merkt, dass beide Seiten echt ziemlich
am Ende sind, aber eben wirklich beide.
Also jetzt beide sind schlapp, beide ziehen noch durch, aber es hat ja keiner
richtig die Oberhand in der Ukraine.
Also in den letzten Wochen sieht man, die Ukraine, die schieben die Russen nicht
schnell, aber so ein Stück hier, ein Stück da.
Also so ein Hauch positiv für die Ukraine, würde ich sagen, derzeit.
Aber noch nicht, dass ich applaudieren würde, weil man sagt,
warte, das ist alles, wir reden wirklich noch von ein bisschen hier,
ein bisschen da. Das ist jetzt, die stehen noch nicht vor Moskau, ne?
Und ich meine, sowas dreht sich ja auch langsam. Also gerade,
also wir hatten jetzt ja, wie gesagt, wenn man auf der Karte mal rauszoomt,
hatten wir jetzt drei Jahre Stillstand mal, grob gesagt.
Wenn man näher rankommt, ja hier vor, da zurück, das finde ich ist immer so ein Kleinkram.
Darum geht es am Ende nicht, wer einen Meter vorgerückt ist, an welchem Tag.
An der einen Fahrt zu Pokrovk stand vor kurzem noch so ein Schild,
so ein selbst gemaltes, denkt dran, Jungs, wir müssen nur einen Tag länger durchhalten als Sie.
Ich glaube, das ist so derzeit das Motto da auch, dass alle sagen,
ja, es ist echt übel, es ist schlecht, wir haben jetzt dies und das.
Ich meine, auch mit den Häfen, die sie jetzt bombardiert haben,
davon ist Russland ja nicht jetzt pleite. Das sind ja alles immer Sachen, das dauert.
Also, es zieht sich und dauert und auch, ich meine, es hieß im Mai 2022,
die Russen haben im Prinzip keine Panzer mehr.
Na ja, okay, noch so ein paar alte, aber Ende 2022 haben die keine mehr.
Aber Ende 2023 haben die Russen echt keine Panzer mehr.
Aber Ende ist es jetzt wirklich, also jetzt haben die, und man sagt,
ja, ja, abwarten, abwarten.
Also wenn man nichts auf sein Volk gibt und nichts auf seinen Staat im Prinzip,
kann man eine Menge durchhalten, wenn man alles, also wie im Iran auch,
wenn du alles runterraspelt bis zum Umfallen, da geht eine Menge.
Deswegen wäre ich da mit allem noch sehr vorsichtig.
Aber ich sehe es jetzt, dass es tendenziell für die Ukraine in den letzten Wochen
oder in diesem Jahr so ein Hauch positiv läuft.
Aber alles sehr vorsichtig. Und ich denke, dieses Jahr wird sich eine Menge
entscheiden, weil die Sache mit dem Iran, also kommt das Regime wieder hoch, was ich leider erwarte.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die sie jetzt abgesägt kriegen und der Iran demokratisch
ist. Also auch noch so ein Punkt, wer soll denn sich da zur Wahl stellen, mit welcher Partei?
Also wenn es dann mal, die Leute stellen sich so vor, du knallst den einen ab
und am nächsten Tag haben sie eine Demokratie.
So, nee, das dauert. Also guck dir den Erfolgsfall Irak an, nachdem Saddam weg war.
Wie lange hat es gedauert, bis hier eine erfolgreiche, friedliche Demokratie
wurden? So, wir warten noch.
Aber ich denke, in diesem Jahr wird zumindest einiges kippen.
Also das mit dem Iran, zumindest sind sie geschädigt.
Also die werden erstmal sagen, hey Russland, wir müssen hier ein bisschen konsolidieren.
Lass uns Freunde bleiben, aber ich melde mich später.
Ich meine, China und Russland, Freunde waren die nie. Also es ist halt ein Kunde
für China oder so. Aber es ist jetzt aber, also wie es immer heißt,
die Chinesen haben noch nie einen Dollarschein gesehen, den sie nicht mochten.
Also es kommt einfach darauf an, wer einen guten Deal anbietet.
Deswegen denke ich, für die Russen wird es auf jeden Fall schlechter dieses Jahr.
Aber ob es richtig schlecht wird oder wie lange die sich durchwürgen,
das finde ich ist so schwer abzusehen, weil theoretisch haben die schon,
also sie haben ja quasi einmal ihre ganze Armee verloren, so in Mann.
Sie haben quasi einmal all ihre Panzer verloren.
Sie haben einen Teil ihrer strategischen Bomberflotte verloren,
ja, aber sie sind immer noch in der Ukraine.
Also so einfach mit Zahlen und so ist es dann am Ende nicht.
Also ich glaube, dieses Jahr werden wir eine Menge Bewegung und Entscheidung
sehen, so vor allem über den Sommer.
Aber wohin das Pendel dann am Ende kippt, denke ich, boah.
Und sagen wir mal, die Russen würden den Krieg verlieren und Putin wäre tot.
Dann heißt das ja immer noch nicht, dass irgendwie die ganze Nummer davon vorbei
ist. Was hieße das dann wieder?
Also es ist ja nicht, dass wir sozusagen sagen, wenn dieser Punkt erreicht ist,
dann tanzen wir alle im Kreis und halten uns an den Händen und die Welt ist
okay, sondern es ist ja, also egal.
Das Ende von Putin wäre definitiv auch das Ende dieses Konfliktes,
also des konkreten derzeit stattfindenden Konfliktes.
Da gehe ich von aus, nur was heißt das dann für Russland, haben wir dann das
nächste Problem. Also das meine ich so.
Ich finde das ist zu viel unklar. Die Welt hat noch genug Reservoir an Krisen und genug Potenzial.
Ich denke, sehr viel wird sich auch daran festmachen,
wie es jetzt Trump und den Republikanern in den USA ergeht, inwiefern die USA
sich wehren können wird gegen die offensichtlichen Versuche,
diese Wahl auszusetzen oder zumindest so weit zu drehen, dass sie immer noch
behaupten können, sie hätten jetzt irgendwas gewonnen.
Das wird, glaube ich, so ein bisschen das Hauptproblem sein.
Aber was auf jeden Fall schwindet, ist halt der...
Der politische Einfluss der USA in Europa.
Und in der Welt, also auch im Nahen Osten.
Also generell überall, aber sagen wir mal jetzt auch spezifisch mit Blick auf die Ukraine.
Europa, die Ukraine macht es ja in gewisser Hinsicht jetzt schon vor und sagt
so, ja nö, wie brauchen wir dir denn jetzt hier mal so helfen da in der Ostsee.
So, uns doch egal, was ihr davon haltet. So, ihr helft uns ja eh nicht.
Also, und das ist glaube ich das, was die USA noch nicht gecheckt haben,
dass sie einfach dadurch, dass sie permanent jetzt gesagt haben,
wir brauchen euch alle nicht, dann sagen die halt so, naja, wenn ihr uns nicht
braucht, dann brauchen wir euch halt dann auch nicht mehr so sehr.
Ja, auch so eigentlich Kleinkram, aber diese Vormachtstellung der Amis,
also so Sachen wie, dass Leute hier Tesla nicht mehr haben wollen,
nicht wegen den technischen Specs,
sondern wie Musk sich verhält, das konnten ja auch viele in den USA gar nicht
fassen, weil es geht doch um Business und das Auto.
Und ich meine, da bröselst du nur so eine Ecke. Aber auch, dass jetzt Staaten
in Europa sagen, wir müssen mal weg von Visa und Mastercard.
Also zumindest, also auch so Dinge, man sagt, okay, davon ist Trump nicht weg.
Aber so dieses, und ich meine, dass Leute von Google weg wollen und so,
okay, das haben wir länger.
Aber mir scheint, das nimmt mehr Fahrt auf. Nicht, dass wir die Lösung haben.
Aber dass es eine ernsthafte, größere Diskussion gibt zu so,
vielleicht sollten wir jetzt mal ernsthaft Alternativen aufbauen.
Ich glaube, das sind eben auch wieder so Sachen, das ist nicht heute und nicht
morgen, aber vielleicht so in einem Jahr oder so, dass wir unsere EU-Kreditkarten
haben, was auch einfach an dieser Weltmacht Amiland überall so rechts und links kratzen würde.
Das finde ich so Faktoren, die auch, das war früher, wenn du gesagt hast,
nutze halt kein Google, ja, das war so ein verrückter Nerd.
Okay, so schnitzt dir dein Linux.
Aber dass solche Sachen einfach mehr im Mainstream ankommen auch,
Das, finde ich, nimmt man auch so jede Woche so ein Stück mehr wahr.
Genau und das wird im Idealfall zu einer Konsolidierung, glaube ich,
auch der europäischen Bewegung führen, so wie ja eigentlich nahezu alles nach
hinten losgeht, was Trump derzeit anfasst.
Letztlich ist das ja auch, der ganze Iran-Krieg mustert sich jetzt langsam so
zu der erfolgreichsten Kampagne für erneuerbare Energien, die die Welt je gesehen hat.
Und von daher stimmt mich das bei all dem Elend, was dort unten gerade angerichtet
wird auf beiden Seiten, so halbwegs optimistisch.
Dass die 20er vielleicht doch noch mal die Kurve kriegen. Läuft ja nicht so gut bisher.
Offen wie es.
Alright, Enor. Vielen Dank für deine Ausführungen.
Und belassen wir es jetzt erstmal für diese Ausgabe.
Das war's. UKW. Ich hoffe, das war für euch interessant und hat euch neue Einblicke geliefert.
Demnächst mache ich dann mit Paffel hier wahrscheinlich wieder weiter und dann
gucken wir nochmal auf ein paar interessante Details. Und bis dahin sage ich Tschüss, bis, tschüss.